I guess we sure used to the normal
dynamics in anime yeah rather like a hot
girl turns up and he wants to have sex
with her but then he actually just start
the [ __ ] [ __ ] you know I'm like who
is this charge like I've never seen such
a big child in anime that's what the
[ __ ]
welcome to trash taste I'm your host
Connor and I'm tired as [ __ ]
we just we all just hit a very strong
coffee but I'm again with Joey ah and
gone
no no nicknames today oh I just didn't
think to do that or I'm keeping it
simple I mean that's who we are right
I'm very tired every every day before we
do an episode I wake up at 7 a.m. to go
to a Japanese class for two hours I was
like going for you it's going it's going
forward sometimes you're too tired to
learn things and I remember being like
this in university I would be like
asleep basis yeah but then they make you
talk so I kind of yeah like how's it
going for you cuz like me and Connor
have gone very different routes in terms
of our how we've approached learning
Japanese because you've taken classes
and I'm like completely like self-taught
because I realized in university how
classes really like slowed me down in
terms of my learning process yeah just
the biggest problem I've encountered is
self-discipline that's exactly what I
wanted laughs because cuz the way I see
it right lessons are like okay if I'm
keeping up with these lessons these are
like the bare minimum that someone at
any mental capacity can learn Japanese
right so if I'm learning it at this
structured course that anyone can do
right I should learn X amount of
Japanese yeah because we know that like
everyone who's like homeschooled doesn't
actually like do anything and also I'm
like a liar dude I lie to myself a lot
like when I say I'm gonna learn Japanese
I will do everything in my power to like
think that I'm learning Japanese like
like like during the quarantine because
at this point in the episode it's it's
it's pretty much done it's pretty much
open but like during the quarantine
because you know Connor you can go to
Japanese lessons really you had to do
like zoom lessons I hated you and you
and you were telling you that like most
of the time you were just playing arc
night
like yes I am listening teachers like oh
yeah problem was right is that I was in
a my class is mainly like housewives and
like people who are much older than me
yeah right so a lot of them wouldn't
weren't tech savvy so they were all
spending ten minutes saying hello hello
can you hear me hello meanwhile I'm like
already set up I've got my whole YouTube
is set up right okay yeah two monitors
three mobile phones you know what I mean
like you got the green screen yeah the
pro streamer said like you know it's
just like when when I'm at my PC mmm
like I'm doing everything but what I'm
supposed to be doing right so I got two
monitors right so I can also put my
webcam over the [ __ ] out one so and
they're like are you looking and I'm
like a family yeah doing work on the
other monitor yeah yeah like and I know
you're like well Connor you're paying
for those lessons why would you not do
it I don't know I paid to be in class
you know yeah that's like that's like
University in a nutshell yeah I mean
you're you're paying to be here you're
paying to learn right oh why do I have
to get a class yeah I can just study
from home I hate going to the class and
having to do that and be back in that
environment cuz you know yeah how do
they get out of that but at the same
time I am learning stuff like it is slow
and I do a lot of study a minor in time
mainly khan sheikh sayed own teachers
kanji yeah it's it's practical japanese
so it's all supposed to be for like
speaking because it's my to reiterate I
when I say classes I think most people
will assume like everyday ah I do
classes two times a week for two hours
that's it yeah so not a lot of time to
learn a language
really right right so it's better than
nothing I guess it's much better than
doing nothing right exactly
cuz for me like I've tried to focus less
on the reading and just pure
conversational for me yeah and actually
one thing that's really helped with that
is not watching anime actually but yeah
but watching virtual youtubers so I've
like I've like really gotten into
watching virtual youtubers last few
months yeah who are you into um hasta
Coco is probably my favorite on earth at
the time of right now she just had a 3d
debut I'm sounding like a total [ __ ]
determiner is that the one you like
seemed over
yeah we show that all over Twitter was
gone I was very drunk at the time and I
thought she was like she was having like
her first 3d debut and I'm like I'll
just [ __ ] throw it throw like 30
bucks whatever and then like as soon as
I did like my Twitter notifications
imagine getting called simple whatever
virtual you know because like it's
actually really helped my Japanese way
more than watching anime because with
watching anime like I don't know what
the anime watching experience has been
for you Connor since you start learning
but for me I found it a lot more
difficult to watch anime now that I'm
learning Japanese because you know you
know when you like read the subtitles
yeah and then you kind of understand
what's going on so you want to like try
to listen in to what's what's being said
but but because you do that you kind of
just miss what's what's on the subtitles
that's like been my anime watching
experience recently and well I imagine
Joey sit on his throne here being like
yes tell me more about your struggle
what are these subtitles and speak oh hi
okay one thing that I noticed that bugs
me is that now that I know like I'd say
like a very basic amount right very
minute yeah like not not enough to watch
an episode and be like yep I understand
all that but I have to like get some
sentences right is that when I read the
subtitles and all supercruise in
Japanese sometimes the subject at the
end of the sentence in English right yes
I only the start Japanese so sometimes
you'll see a subtitle that comes with
the other half of the sentence so you're
hearing the it's gonna come out yes like
Johnson Joestar
your next line is gonna be yaki and it
kind of messes with you and then also
like just watching any hentai it's
really pretty frustrating because I'm
more like I've realized like two minutes
in I'm starting to be like okay like I
guess though it makes sense to like
watch v tubers though to like learn
Japanese because like you know this is
these are real people like speaking
right they just look like anime but like
their mannerisms and their phrasing even
though you know they might be playing
like a character right yeah it's still
like a real pub cause it feels like
they're having an actual conversation
because you know like watching watching
an anime and hear conversation you know
you're like know what I've never seen a
real converse is in a real conversation
that's happening right now and I'm like
zoning most of it out whereas when I'm
watching a youtuber it feels like a
genuine like a Japanese conversation
like you're actually hearing a story the
way like any any person you talk to
Japan yeah look like yeah so it's been
like way more useful for me in learning
Japanese than it has been watching anime
also because I guess like with features
again they're like real people right so
like the the speed that they talk at is
well is very real yes like not like
overly accentuated so it actually makes
more sense to like get used to that kind
of speech yes speed then like no cuz you
know like it's it's like the anime voice
I think voice yeah I mean which is which
is not how real people talk like and is
this is true in like I'd say dub as well
you know you hear like a double act ER
or like a dub performance and you're
like this this isn't how real people
talk this is how kids it's very anime
you know so yeah so it's like it's it's
more like watching a live stream oh so
it's been like I'm not gonna say that's
I'm gonna I'm not gonna say that's the
only reason I've been into you v tubers
but it's actually if you're trying to
learn Japanese I'd say V tubing is much
more useful the learning is educational
I swear
because watching anime now for me has
become a lot harder and you get the joy
of finding that 1v2 but you can see
that's a little bit annoying to watch
anime sometimes but then also now
sometimes I can look away just for a
second and I can still understand what
they said roughly because I'll know like
three of the the five words that they
say and yeah I had a piece together what
was being so yeah that's such a like a
gratifying moment it really is and as
well like one thing that I found really
helpful then I thought I would dread is
like learning kanji I think learning
kanji is so interesting I know you love
your conscience yeah yeah but learning
has been so fun because when it slowly
starts to make sense it feels like an
RPG where you're unlocking the world
where you live right yeah I can slowly
start to read stuff and then there's
like multiple different like ways to
read a kanji and then when you like know
both it's like yeah I like that you like
that one is Sakai protag right right
comes in is like what does this say like
twelve episodes in it's like yeah I get
it yeah it's been really helpful for
like just learning like speaking it in
general because a lot of the words have
the same pronunciation and then
obviously kanji is there like way to
differentiate kanji like holds the
meaning right yeah yeah and sometimes
reading a whole sentence and hero
Donner's it's like it is a nightmare
it's it's weirdly enough like if for
people who'd like to have no idea about
Japanese it might be hard to like think
about but yeah a full-on like hiragana
or katakana sentence is so difficult to
read sometimes yeah whereas countries
just like oh yeah I know exactly what
that means I know exactly how to read it
it's the way I see it is that in English
is that how we don't need to read the
word we know the shape of the wood you
know you can see a word I know the shape
of the wood I can read it right and I
think that's how kanji is the Japanese
people where they they don't necessarily
read it but they recognize that a shape
and they just know what's being said in
the sentence so you see in that video
where you can read like an entire
paragraph where you fits if it's the
word is the first letter is the same the
last letter say and you swap all the
letters in the middle you can still read
yeah yeah just because of how your
fluency works yeah and I feel like it
would be the same with kanji as well I
think so yeah yeah it is the same but
instead of the first and last letters
it's like does this have one line in it
or two like you just have to like it's
that but just squinting really hard
okay yeah there's some where there's so
many lines or I'm like how the factory
would just like read it this fast like
it's I mean the more difficulty is going
to start to write it right yeah because
I have like an app and then it like it
like vibrates my phone if you do the
wrong stroke order because whenever I do
write a kanji out in my class in like
the right stroke order the teachers like
like in the TV show what [ __ ] because
like you never really think about
something like stroke order you know
which stroke order is basically well
order
you've writes it in yeah cause like I
write my asses the wrong way in English
and people freaking tell people how you
write your asses I do push there from
top to bottom
yeah most people don't yeah I do if I do
from the bottom up
yeah like swish down with the cursive I
know why I'm like like how did you love
that I I I was like I was so bad at
English in school so to clarify right
like okay I'll just I'll just start the
story with this we'll start strong right
I was so bad at English that they like
put me with the kids who you know were
not good at anything you know like yeah
yeah yeah with I was in like the English
class for one year would like kids with
learning disabilities Yeah right and I
remember being like dude what the [ __ ]
okay I've always been like really good
at most subjects in school and okay to
clarify the reason why my English was so
bad cuz the only reading and writing I
ever did was in Welsh my schools watch
today or everything I I spoke in school
and read was in watch but I also see
knew how to spell English I speak
English obviously and then yeah I
remember I we did like an English
spelling test
I got like everything wrong but bear in
mind I was like eight and I couldn't I
remember they said like are can you
spell the word said for us I was like
yeah sure
and I just put like a CD but like yeah
like Zed Edie yeah and and then there
and then my parents like oh no mind like
I never read anything in English the
reading at all it should always video
games so so yeah and I've got one was at
wider this story come up I forgot
saying this is weird yeah so I think I
learned how to write because in English
is well they they in school they teach
you the stroke order I just I can't
remember this I mean I I learnt it when
we had to I don't know if this is only
in Australia but like yeah I think I was
in like fourth grade also I should have
those papers which are half-width and
forward yeah yeah I learned how to do
when we want to write cursive
yeah because we've already incur Civ and
it kind of became thing where for some
reason I just started writing some of
them weirdly and no one ever stopped me
and so so I just have always done like
I'll go into like the a and then I'll go
down and do the s up and then slash down
how do you write your little item number
five do you go from the bottom or do you
from the top it depends I guess like
whatever
what if it depends yeah I don't know
like sometimes how does that time I
would do it from the top but I remember
distinctively I was doing it from the
bottom for a while and then I stopped
that but I also used to write my falls
like the correct way being for wait do
you how do you learn right for such I do
I do it this way I do it that's the way
I learn but then I remember I was
playing brain training and they wouldn't
accept that way of writing for this is
when I was like eleven so then I started
having to write falls in the
Americanized way which is doing that way
and then like that that's the
Americanized way well it's uh well I
think so yeah well you do like if looks
like I'd like a kind of like spiky nine
right I don't think I write any letters
starting from the bottom no no I'm like
always how are you do your force fought
like this oh yeah I do it the opposite
way I think yeah yeah so you do from the
bottom yeah from the bottom and then I
go what do you do that I don't know some
weird so in school did you have to learn
English literature and language what's
they different like this because they
were two different subjects for us in
school oh no we just said English Irish
it could see I had to learn English
literature English language Welsh
literature and wash language I [ __ ]
hated doing that man okay cuz I think
for us like maybe this is my school
maleic it depended on the day of the
week so like unlike it was like on
Mondays we go through like a literature
for like the turn that we have to study
and then on like Wednesdays we like got
to like do something else like watch
them
like study a different text for like a
certain thing or like how to read an
essay and write an essay on Fridays and
she like that's a yeah we didn't I think
it's because though just my school is
just very small as well so I probably
wasn't enough English teachers in our
schools your the literature one and your
the comprehension one you know yeah how
does it feel like learning a new
language as your order now though
compared to when you're a kid because
like I remember we had to learn a lot of
other languages when we're when we were
in school and then vanish French didn't
take any of that Shin arm but it's been
like a very different challenge learning
Japanese as like a grown adult I would
say because I don't know has the fact
that you were very much into Japanese
culture and watching anime helped you at
all from your perspective definitely I
think it's made it easier but like easy
with an asterisk right yes like yeah
easier to understand some concepts
culturally that might explain some of
the language right which is great but at
the end of the day it doesn't help me
like in a crazy amount yeah I think it
just helps me understand why certain
things are the way they are in a
language yeah you know why is it like
you know while you can't be direct to
someone why why toy sue my senel yeah
it's never you know and then I guess
because sometimes in your learning a
language you're like why can't I just be
like direct yeah that's not a thing you
can't do that that's it that's true yeah
I think learning Japanese for me I
didn't realize how much I kind of just
zoned out Japanese when I watched anime
before yeah you do you filter it out
because you're like that's that's
nonsense to me I'm yeah yeah you you
just like absorbing the subtitles and
kind of just mute out the Japanese and I
didn't realize that until I started
learning when I when I actually picked
out individual like how the sentence
works and how how the language actually
works that I realize oh oh this didn't
help me a lot at all but I find it
really hard in my head to recommend
learning language to people because I'm
I feel like if you're not gonna like
actually do it mm-hmm it's kind of a
waste of time I know it takes commit
yeah that's what I said to people though
about Japanese and it's one of those
things where like learning Japanese
especially if you're not if you're not
going to do it full-time
it's like at least a five year thing
that you have to commit to and if you
quick two and a half years in you know
but that's the private rights that like
so many people I get cracking emails
about it all - god damn being what's the
easiest way to learn Japanese there is
no easy way to learn Japanese no you
just have to sit down and just be like
am I about to commit five to ten years
of my life to learn this [ __ ] yes it's
like any like skill chart right where
it's like the first like real getting
over the first real difficult like that
yeah yes the hardest and once you get
past that you've gone through a
challenge
yeah overcome it normally you can keep
going let's say with any craft right
like voice acting as well like
photography anything right YouTube thank
you yeah there's always like gonna be
that that first point where you think
you're starting to understand it then
you get to that point we all like [ __ ] I
know nothing about yeah and it's that
point where if you keep going and
actually like starting you know really
put in the work you'll probably see some
results but a lot people quit at that
point cuz like I'm always really
paranoid and this is true in my life and
whenever I'm like doing a playthrough of
the game right when I'm doing something
and it's just sub optimized yes like
sometimes I like paralyzed myself
because I'm just like what if I'm not
doing this most optimal ways this waste
of time I'm so scared of wasting my time
so when I first I'd learning Japanese I
spent more time trying to figure out the
best way to learn Japanese yeah yeah I
guess you're the opposite sorry in that
sense like I do video games I'm
definitely like that
I'll maximize the [ __ ] out of video
games but everything else in my life I'm
like that's kind of the opposite with
video games I'm just like yeah you are
games just made to be like fun and
timely yeah cuz cuz I'll talk to Jerry
about videos are both playing and I'll
be like you know this is like 2% more
efficient to dislike this method right
and Jerry's like oh I don't give a [ __ ]
and I've already put CCI learning a
language there I'm like as long as I'm
learning something in the language that
yeah I can view is somewhat useful I'm
sure it's it's not a waste yeah I'm like
there's Philip there's no route to
learning a language any bit you learn of
it is like it's putting the jigsaw
together like like everyone has a
different path everyone learns
differently and you're not gonna
discover the best way you learn unless
you actually just go out and fail at
like I don't know if I don't [ __ ]
know I would waste like a month on
duolingo there's a lot of time on Julie
don't use foot like other languages
European languages I'm pretty sure it's
pretty good but I took Japanese it was
not very useful yeah yeah it was very
can get you right from the get-go light
and not explaining why you need to learn
it or why what this has sounds efficient
teaching me the kanji for window like
like that's one of the first things yeah
it was hard and like seat kanji for seat
and I thought like why you teach you
this [ __ ] like I don't even know the
kanji for Monday like like why would you
teach me winter I don't need to know
this like if I do everything Windows in
like the the top 100 most used kanji so
why you teach yeah yeah it's pretty
uncommon to say like what like I feel
that the way it when dueling or went
about it I'm at we're never gonna get a
Dueling respond to [ __ ] by the way yeah
it was yeah not good I mean if we do you
can call us our Julie is a wait it like
tricks you into thinking you're learning
no no you you know a lot of like this
useless parotid like pieces of
information that you can never piece
together as a whole to use anywhere
basically yeah and it's a shame cause I
feel you don't really realize that
you're being marked off by dueling or
until like you actually start learning
it properly and you like I literally
have no use for anything I learn on
dueling because it was such it was such
a mess
I remember distinctively right like I
didn't even know how to say any
sentences but they were teaching me how
to read the kanji of Kyoto and Tokyo
yeah that's cool but like I don't need
to know this I genuinely done if you go
to Tokyo and Kyoto it's written in fun
it's like this is something that I don't
need to know what I would like to know
is how do I say like oh I recommend this
yeah yeah I think it's I think you know
like I didn't know how to say I think or
anything like that right it's like I
don't need to know if this is a pen okay
I know this is I know what an apple you
know there's some good stuff down also
it's all bad but I just felt like the
structure was all over the place yeah
cuz I remember when we first moved
before we move to Japan we were on me
and Connor were on duolingo for like a
good month month and a half yeah before
moving to Japan and then we got there
more like oh oh we don't know [ __ ] so we
need we need to start off by learning
hiragana and cats
yeah and I remember we just like I sat
down and I googled like what the best
memorization techniques were and then
ice I found this memorization techniques
like I can't remember what it's called I
think well link it will link it in the
description exordium onyx icon um these
i pronouncing shin over and then i
learned all of hiragana and katakana in
like one day yeah and then I told Connor
yo this this this [ __ ] was I don't know
about this and then I linked him to say
Moscow and he comes back to me like
three four hours later I'm like brah I
can read it was crazy it was like I said
earlier like when you go outside and
like you've unlocked the world yeah
you'd stop suddenly reading McDonald's
menus with nerve is that the one where
it's is the mnemonics thing where it's
like you yeah we shape yeah yeah it
would make you a sign like and and to
fair this is helic memory champions
memorize stuff they design stories and
and shapes and objects to the memory and
that way they can recall them much
easier so it would say like ku which is
the one that's like that they're like
it's a chef's hat yeah give a chef's hat
when you see this symbol
they're like cooky it was like yeah it
was like a sign because then then you
remember that's kind of dumb but then
you remember when you see it oh it's
that dumb thing yeah it's really stupid
but it made you remember it is like
contra counterintuitive right because by
by remembering more stuff you remember
one stuff better as a note is just
repeating the same thing over and over
but the best way I've heard an
explanation of for a is that it's kind
of like a your memories that kinda like
a filing cabinet right yeah so you if
you just have one random piece of
information that you just randomly file
you know they're very hard to just find
that random piece of information but you
have if if that information is got a
bunch of other information that relates
that yeah then it's much easier for you
to like find it in your memory so that's
why you can just makes all things a lot
easier
yeah it's I definitely feel like that
like I find that learning symbols for me
is like way easier than learning like
anything else like that's why like kanji
has been pretty fun so yeah definitely
like a person who like for my stuff like
visually right yeah yeah when I'm like
like if you give me like a set of
numbers I can normally remember the
numbers like decently well like so
learning kanji is great cuz like I love
just putting like a hundred symbols in a
like a program and just making it test
me over and over and I'll do that for
like hours until I can remember all 100
right yeah yeah that's what I do and I
find that pretty easy I see at the end
of the day that's what is probably the
most effective right it's just right
yeah you literally just need to like
force that [ __ ] in your head I just like
doing it doing it doing it and at least
the good thing about doing that here in
Japan is that if you then force yourself
to learn all those symbols is it you
just walk outside you're like yeah you
can like use it like practically all
right yeah yeah yeah like there's some
where I'm like I'm never gonna [ __ ]
like I don't need to know this kanji and
then like two seconds later I'm on the
train and that the place has one of the
colleges and then yeah I get it yeah
which is like question for you Joey
which is I have voice man curious like
how much studying have you done because
a lot of people assume that Joey's
Japanese is like a second language right
and it's completely wrong Joey has a
second first language like a lot of
people don't know this but Joey's
Japanese is better than most Japanese
people yeah it's I had no idea how good
your Japanese was I just kind of thought
that you were like decent huh yeah yeah
I'd like but then I came here and then
you were teaching kanji to like 40 year
old people and they were like what the
[ __ ] I was a party and late we had like
three people from our company Japanese
and I was like teaching them about like
different kanji structures in the [ __ ]
that were like I'd never heard this
before I'm like yeah um I did a lot like
write a lot a lot like when I say I've
said it in videos but like when I've
said like I've studied my entire life
like I'm not joking I've studied my
entire life um just to put it in
perspective when I was like like maybe
10 years old I know what I used to do
for fun whoa I used to read the kanji
dictionary I would literally I was that
one kid I like my parents probably
thought I was like borderline autistic
cuz like I would like to sit in my room
as a ten-year-old and I'm like I know
nothing better to do and I would just go
to my mom's bookshelf just take out this
massive like you know 2000 page country
yeah yeah and just open up to a random
page and just read it yeah well like
hours on in and like I don't know maybe
I don't know how much that actually
helped me in the long run but definitely
it kind of got me like - like
familiarize myself with different shapes
and you know in that sense I'm
definitely a lot like Conaway yeah I'm
very good at learning things with the
only yeah I need visuals I had learning
sentences and stuff doesn't do anything
yeah no but like another huge thing for
me was probably the fact that like my
mom had like this like kind of this
unspoken rule where if I spoke to her in
English I would usually get ignored and
that is really cruel especially when
like a four-year-old is really talk to
their mom about something and like but I
quickly picked up on it because like I
was like four or five years old and I'd
like to be like hey mom can I do you
know blah blah should just straight-up
ignore me I'm like all right she's in a
pissed-off mood but then but then the
more times you experience I'm like oh I
have to ask her in Japanese and the
moment I also in Japanese she's like yes
so that's a genius way to make you yeah
my mom my mom was exactly the same okay
I'm like thank I'm like now she's like
you can appreciate with this when you're
older but if you are you know you're
getting this now mom I appreciate that
now that's also because like if she
didn't do that then I wouldn't have just
like I would have forced myself to learn
Thai or to use Thai you know setting
which is very hard when you're not
living in the country that you're using
exactly you know like everybody around
me spoke English right because I was
living in Australia and like I had a few
like childhood friends who spoke
Japanese but because all my childhood
friends were also hafiz like me yeah
sometimes we just spoke in English to
one another so like I need it away I
guess my mom was like all right I need
to find like a consistent way my son is
you keep speaking the language just keep
improving and like it really helps as
well because my mom was like exceedingly
good at Japanese and kanji and stuff
like that especially so like whenever I
had like a question or like I learned a
new word I always went to my mom and I
try to force myself to use that new word
in a sentence and she would be like she
would either say like oh that's not how
you use that word this is how you use it
dumb little she tell you how to use this
place
immediately no when I was trying to like
where's like I you just want that word
didn't you because she'd be like okay
that's not quite how you use it this is
how you use it and then I use it again
and she'd be like okay perfect and
that's just how I learn from
practicality you know one big reason I
really want to learn Japanese is one
specific series I want to experience
after having learned Japanese yeah and
that's the monogatari see oh yeah I
really really want to experience the
monogatari series after learning
Japanese because like I love the
monogatari series now yeah but I feel
like I'm getting like maybe half the
enjoyment I could be guessing and like
all the appreciation I could get there's
this video I've been trying to write for
the longest time called you'll never
understand initiation where because as
you said the monogatari series and
everything nice uation writes is [ __ ]
phenomenon wait he's an amazing author a
lot of it translates pretty well in
English right but the thing that makes
initiation so amazing is the subtleties
and the way that he plays around with
the Japanese language and that [ __ ] is
[ __ ] impossible to translate yeah and
I wanted to make that video because I
[ __ ] love nishu is you know monetary
series like more than anybody yeah but
it's like how do I explain to my
english-speaking audience about how
you'll never understand it if you're an
English speaker you have like a basic
understanding of kanji right yeah
understand not just kanji it's it's
everything he does would play in a way
that I have never seen any Japanese
author noon and I think that's the whole
reason why so many people loved him it
was like it's like wow I didn't know
that you could like he makes Japanese
people's Japanese look Tom will read
them be like wow it's like I don't know
this language cuz like have you ever
seen the morning Qatari series yeah yeah
I was learning kanji the day and I came
across one I got three country is like
four is it like Hana say all oh cool
which kanji czar the one where you it's
like to speak or to tell a tale is
Holika i'll go yeah yeah go is like one
of the meanings is to tell a tale right
and so it's I cook and one of the Tauri
just means like thing tale yeah yeah
that's what I saw Alec that's pretty
cool yeah because like because like
that's the thing right with the Mona
Vitara series that even the titles are a
play
woods right because [ __ ] Momo and
monogatari is two different words right
just [ __ ] mashes those two words
together to just turn it into one thing
okay and like that's that's like the
brilliant subtlety of any show Asia I
don't want to say the whole thing cuz I
wanna save it for our video okay so I
was gonna ask how is it reading the
light novel compared to watching the
anime because that's something I've
always been curious about how well the
anime has been able to translate his
writing right into a visual format I
think with like that's the one thing I
love about shaft right is that they do
hold this like really weird appreciation
for initiations writing and yeah that's
why like you know other doggies like
monologues are way longer than any anime
monologue Hanoi like there's so much
that's why I would you know being like
what the [ __ ] like we just end like yeah
like like acid and ammonia Atari episode
is like 95% dialogue yeah but it needs
to be because everything that initiation
rights is so important to the story
because it is really convoluted and it
does add a lot of character and like and
you know like if you've seen one of
Atari episodes you know Holly every now
and then there were just like these
flashing images oh yeah that's all text
ripped straight out of the novels yeah I
was really confused no time yeah I've
confused a lot during about every series
of the monitor yeah yeah it is it is
very surprised how big monogatari got
because it like I remember when I first
watched it and I'm like this breaks
basically every rule of like filmmaking
conventions that I know yeah it was like
oh you know show don't tell it what a
guitar is like how about we tell
everybody and show basically nothing and
you're just gonna enjoy this 20 minute
long dialogue yeah and you're gonna
[ __ ] in and and it's it turns out
amazing and I'm like why'd why does this
work I have never seen something work so
eloquently as the monogatari series and
what surprised me is that it just became
like for the otaku culture back then it
kinda mechanic became like a cultural
phenomenon it did especially in Japan
because it was just unlike anything and
I mean you know caught on a got that he
in a sense as well I was gonna say like
if I had to if I was a betting man I
would have put my money on cut on the
gut that I being way bigger than yeah
yeah and it's kind of weird that in the
West it was like the other way around
and like
people still don't really watch I think
capitana got to be because of maybe it's
like I don't know where you can watch it
all right
illegally yeah yeah I have no idea how
you have to buy like a $400 blu-ray oh
that's a shame it is it's got nothing to
do with the monogatari so you know
that's a good thing recently um there
was an OVA adaptation of the first novel
that initially she never wrote it could
be Kitty cycle that's what it was like
it was like a four episode of Yale that
that came out and I was like okay it's
an issue Asian it's essentially the
series that inspired the monogatari
series yeah so I'm like this has to be
be like you know of course every morning
Atari fans gonna watch it no one [ __ ]
watch that OVA
and I was really sad because it is
screaming monogatari vibes it's it's
weird cuz I liked the Monica three
series
I've watched I don't know which part I
got up to her just a lot of it is like
[ __ ] many and I'm like a monkey when
I watch anime I'm like I don't want to
have to like think about like order and
a [ __ ] and you just put something on
right and sometimes you'd like the I
don't know what happened in between the
series sometimes yeah and because it's
so confusing there was so many times
where I would start a season of one of
that franchise I don't know which
[ __ ] one and I was like am I on the
right one or am I just confused because
it's this series look I didn't like
easily the most like that is the number
one question I get past probably the
most what's the old what order should I
watch even that it's not even that comp
okay but even even though if you're
watching in the right order it's such a
confusing show that normally you can get
halfway through the first episode like
season two right and you're like season
2 I really like don't know what's going
on like what am I guess and I didn't
have any idea what's going on the whole
time so right that's the thing right is
that the monetary series like one season
is already confusing enough as it is
like in a enclosed story yeah and when
you look at it on the grand scale of
things it's even more confusing because
basically initiation pull the Quentin
Tarantino pull fictions yeah we like
everything is out of order but it's in
the same universe yeah
oh I mean I don't think it matters that
much honestly as long as you just get
like this it's just [ __ ] Google with
the release order it's stressful there
man it's I've somehow [ __ ] did I how
many times like when I watched the thus
Spoke Rohan cachet of EA's yeah for some
reason he Iraqi when he wrote them gave
them episode numbers in the right of
thing alright so when you're watching
the OVA s they don't do them in order
and but Iraqi never do them in order
anyway if I remember correctly so your
turn episode 1 they'll be like episode 6
and I'm like please stop
you like spacebar right [ __ ] Google
right which episode is episode 1
yeah episode 1 is episode 6 episode 2 is
episode 9 episode 3 is like episode 4
and then you're like why they like full
people like a George Lucas Star Wars
right it's like episode 4 is the first
one yeah at least it's ghost episode
what like three four five six one two
it's not even that it's just like four
nine to seven
yeah that's like why it's like this not
nothing
just how he Suzumiya like did you watch
are you sorry when it was airing yes so
how he season Mia had like this
broadcast order and it was it was full
absolutely no reason
it was just broadcasted in this random
order and people like I remember when it
was when I was airing people were like
oh this is like a genius move because
it's kind of like you're piecing
together the puzzle each episode and now
that it's like all aired now like I'm
pretty [ __ ] sure that they aired out
the order because the [ __ ] last
episode chronologically was just the
most anticlimactic episode of the entire
series so they're like are the best
episode is episode 6 fix it up just just
mix up the order and people gonna call
that genius crew so it wasn't genius
tiny Colnago was just on crew way resist
which is the original Japanese broadcast
yeah cuz tiny corner girl was on a crack
I didn't know that I see I only watched
it years after and now you mentioned
this before but I watched the movie
first by accident yeah yeah yeah
dumb mistake yeah this this guy can I I
think you mentioned in episode zero so
most people have seen this person watch
the disappearance of haruhi suzumiya
first which is like I wish I was still
less confused watching that movie then I
was watching most them on igano so if
you don't know the they made a movie
right of like the thing that like tied
the whole hat excuse me it was yeah the
disappearance of suzumiya haruhi which
is the fourth boy novel I don't know why
no I don't [ __ ] know right oh I was
like I was in I just got into anime I
wanted to watch the best rated anime
movie you know no one told me and it's
really is the best no one who told me
that I needed backstory you know and I
went into it I I I watched it all and I
was like well you know what did you
think it did you think it was a good
movie [ __ ] I bet kono just watch this
right after school days ten or ten ten
hours and what the [ __ ] is going on
well I'm like I am I'm on crack I think
I think the school days as well like you
know broke the camel's back yeah it was
definitely the Hannah here Suzumiya
movie watching thing that definitely
like made me think like reviews gone
back to like watch them yes since then I
watched the first season in the TV
series I got like two episodes into the
second TV series where they were
repeating everything okay I would say
that I've already he still is very much
worth watching yeah in this day and age
because of disappearance disappearance
is still my it's probably my favorite
anime franchise film of all time I agree
and up up there is one of my favorite
anime films of all time and this this
guy apparently [ __ ] hates it so I
think that the whole series just kind of
mediocre I don't really I'd the first
season was just fine right I was
watching it and I was like okay I know
this is a terrible comparison but I was
just like man this just feels like
Toradora but like worse this zero
romance
Oh cuz the whole setting reminded me so
much of like Toradora and the way that
it was said that it was set in a school
yeah I know this is like complete soup
and opinion oh my god
I recognize this is a garbage opinion
but the whole time I was just like I
guess cuz he was just okay I was very
bored a lot of the time what she had is
the only thing that made me want to
watch it was the fact that uh
Crispin Freeman voice kion yeah he was
amazing I would use a tree watching him
yeah what you said he's like saying oh
yeah I know Hana was kind of like
another because they have ghosts what
show can you compare Harris use Amir to
if you had to the closest comparison
here's the thing like Harry Suzumiya
inspired a lot of like III came after
that that huge way I became an anime fan
after that huge thing that had its
impact right so I think I came into it
with like zero attachment to it any
sense yeah because I think the thing was
hierarchy that I find really interesting
is the fact that it's one of those anime
that is like really weirdly tied to the
period that it came out in much like
lucky star I feel because like that's
why I don't give a [ __ ] about a unit
right because like the thing the thing
is like I [ __ ] love both lucky star
especially lucky star I think it's
[ __ ] amazing but like the problem is
is that the references in lucky star and
like the whole fact that it really
reflected the otaku culture of yeah is
what made that show really funny in the
mid-2000s but yeah as much as I love
lucky star I can't really recommend it
to people today no and because the scene
is just completely changed yeah but does
that mean you can recommend how he sees
him here today yes I can yeah because I
think I think I ruined it for myself
yeah yeah I think you you basically just
watched the climax you you watch the
climax before like watching any of the
build-up yeah so now you that's why I
kind of don't feel bad for being like
yeah I think it's not that good because
I'm like I know I ruined it for myself
and it might have been the only way to
like top that experiences if you
committed to reading all the light novel
that and like the final final volume of
he was like pretty [ __ ] good so I
just have to sit every night early I
have no I have no interest in reading a
light novel ever cuz I remember like a
lot of the elements in herre he have
been done another place in that cause
like there's a lot of like
self-referential humor in herre he I
remember when that was like an
innovative thing like everyone every
[ __ ] light novel wasn't wasn't trying
to parody every [ __ ] every other
light novel yeah ya know it's just it's
just gotten so [ __ ] lazy with its
self-referential humor again like that's
the whole thing where it comes to like
the time period I like animate boomers
we had it better back in oh six when her
he and lucky star came out like as you
said like the whole like
self-referential thing and I think the
whole meta aspect yeah anime was just so
new like I remember it was such waste
modernism at the time because like I
remember like at the end of every lucky
star beside while the credits were
rolling there was no ending song for
lucky stuff what it was was it was the
scenes of all of the lucky star
characters in a karaoke booth but you
were outside of the karaoke booth so you
could only hear them but the
conversations that they were having in
the karaoke booth weren't characters
having a conversation with characters it
was voice actresses having a
conversation with voice actresses yeah
and people like of course they're voiced
by voice actresses
these aren't just characters on a screen
they're real people and that meta was
like that was [ __ ] cool because no
other anime did that laughing sit down
you're gonna sit down and you're gonna
respect this culture matter anime like I
still think meta anime peaked with
monogatari like in terms of like light
novel light novel yeah shows adaptations
it kind of like Pete with mornig Atari
and there's there's been another good
light novel shows as well I've been
better but I'd say you know Hera he
really was the first time I noticed it
Harry it was Harry he and Lucky Star and
then monogatari was the one that came
afterwards and then it kind of like
nothing out did it and now
now you see a lot of lazy [ __ ]
attempts a meta humor and meta jokes
like there was what one and one anime I
saw recently which was like such an eye
rolling moment is the the milfy sekai
for ads last year okay okay because it
was you know everyone thought and you
know it kind of marketed itself as like
a parody of the easy right because it's
like oh it's the east like a genre but
you know there's a mom this time and i
you can eat it's different it's
different because there's a mom this
time and I remember there was one joke
okay they're in like they're at there
were in a hot springs right and this is
one single a that's in the hot springs
and then she like she like stands up and
she's naked in front of the main
character and then the main character
literally says ah this is the scene
where you're about to hit me right and
there goes our but how about if I don't
hit you I bet you weren't expecting that
were you and the main character goes ah
you're right
I wasn't expecting that and the cinder a
just goes off crying and that was the
joke wow that was the joke I remember I
remember we have this exact same
conversation that is the kaity Liz video
you're like [ __ ] lights fuming a
white this is not how you write a
message ugh you basically explained that
the meds are before you told the mental
first of all I want all my anime scenes
acted out by God like that yeah second
of all I just like where as you said you
tend to watch the trash Lisa Chi I could
give a less with [ __ ] about the East can
see I'm right there it's so like it's
iterates on itself and then changes one
thing it's like yeah it's like I'm
wouldn't be surprised this is another
slime one except he's like a green slime
next right it's just like that's gonna
be the next base just season two yes
this is a green and it's just like I
just I just struggle to give a [ __ ]
about any of these are kinda come on
like I wanted to watch the mum one just
for the memes yeah I couldn't even
muster up to like tighten up in yes it
wasn't even that good for the memes like
it was it was it was you saw the title
you're like haha I can make him email
this and if I did yeah and then I
watched two episodes I'm like now I'm
done
I won't watch these Sherry's so I can
talk about them but then I realized like
if I now maybe I don't even know that
six months after that shares add that
that meme is long dead and no one's
gonna mention it's like by the time the
next season comes around three months
time no one's [ __ ] and then maybe
it'll be like a factoid one day George
some mommy's okay
yeah you need to watch it because for me
watching trash ISA guy or just trash
anime in general because apparently
that's my brand or whatever it's just
the reason I do it is because it's just
like it's just the easy turn your brain
off show the season right now you know
like I have to be in a certain mood to
watch something like Monogatari you know
enemy like I'll just be like oh and just
like casually sit down having having
like my lunch or something I'm like I'm
gonna I'm always like the antithesis of
I'm just gonna put something on yeah
whereas whereas we've with the trashy so
guy like I just sit down for lunch and I
just put it on you know and I just don't
have to think I watch every week and
then I just end and those the shows end
up watching because then they're like
the easiest watch cuz I I know I'm
getting into I'm not being challenged
you know I'm just like okay this
characters gonna do that whatever how
much of a brain did you know which which
is why I can watch them because they are
brains I don't have to think yes you
know you know sometimes where you watch
like a good show right and something
sometimes you just really want to be in
that right mood to watch something good
but with some with the trash shows I
never have to be in a certain mood the
sriracha you know which is why I've
found I found that I've watched more
trash shows because like like sometimes
I don't know I I get ink I get anxiety
sometimes when if I know it's not sure
if it's a good show but a mood do you
know what I mean
what was the show keep your hands off
okay right right like that was one of
those shows where I'm like I can't just
not like I can't just like watch this
yeah yeah you have to commit to it it's
such a passionate thing where I was like
yeah just half ask this so it's one
episode and I liked what I saw
yeah but because of that I I just never
watched episode two because yeah I had
to be in that mood to watch it never was
yeah it's like really
hard to like him stop and then get back
into yeah and it sucks because I know
that was a good show I know it was but I
just I didn't care enough to like find
that time to be like I want to keep
watching this and I thought no bad kiss
like everyone was like this is the best
show of the season yeah I'm just sitting
there like watching like the 100th
documentary on Netflix you know right
because a lot more with anime recent I
feel this this is the reason this is the
[ __ ] reason I still haven't watched
fullmetal alchemist okay yeah no it's
good I know it's good and I like because
here's the thing I can go years without
watching or reading a manga over of a
series that I know I'm going to love I
but I want to be in the right mood and
it might take years it might take a
[ __ ] decade okay like last year I
finally read 20th century boys okay and
it went from like I know I was gonna
read this since I basically started
getting into manga - okay yeah this is
like I thought one of my favorite
mongers of all time yeah and it's
[ __ ] incredible it's what I had to
wait like so many years to experience it
because I just wanted to be in that
perfect zone to read it and I'm so glad
I did because there are some shows you
Jeff some shows that you think if you re
watch it you won't enjoy as much oh you
know what the same heads 90% I think
yeah yeah because I feel like that's why
I caught and I can never get behind
watching anime weekly cuz me can I can't
I I can't because it's because like I'm
always in a different headspace
sometimes oh there's some shows that
like transcend that and like you they're
so hype such as attack on Titan watching
that Weekly was like - [ __ ] every single
week no matter what that one day it came
out I was hyped as [ __ ] for that [ __ ]
cuz I binge that Halsey right yeah like
it was such a good episode by episode
that like even though it sucked
it sucked have to wait a week it was so
good cuz that one day in the week you
got like a tree and didn't matter how
bad your mood was away your headspace is
that for 25 minutes you just shut your
brain off and just have a [ __ ] time
a man I used to be able to do that so
easily when I was in my high school in
uni but and is well joining inin like
this the discourse online you know like
talking about I feel I feel like that's
a different side that I never got
growing up with anime which is the
social aspects because for me it was
just I watch a show and I'm like that
was an amazing show and happy I want to
talk has quickly become one of my
favorite parts of like watching anime
and it's why I like I caught up to demon
slayer on episode 19 yeah like I wanted
to get involved with the the social
discourse good the great like it's it's
made of so if a show has like a bad
ending or something I still enjoy it
because like I remember when darling the
Franks ended and there was this shift at
like episode 18 or 20 icon room the
exact episode and then everyone lost
their [ __ ] and like it's not a good
ending but I had a blast watching it you
know I just realized something
I remember that you know when Big Ed was
a thing I know bear with me the shit's
gonna make sense but you get from that
day fiancé was like it was you know
great memes fantastic I want to start
watching named a fiance because of that
yeah I was like it's just like not the
same I was watching you and I was like
ah it's cuz I need the YouTube comments
for everything cuz it's like one thing
to have a clip is it's funny but what is
like just the perfect YouTube threads do
so fine like and also when someone's an
[ __ ] at even show you want to be like
everyone else thinks this guy's an
[ __ ] right let me go check the
comments yeah because do you get this
now where you watch some YouTube videos
or clip some shows or YouTube video
where they do something in the clip and
that's the moment where you open up the
comments yeah I hope I hope everyone's
talking about this and that's what I
love about watching anime weekly is that
you get that kind of like everyone's
gonna be talking about that thing that
just happened on to it yeah probably fun
I love trying again on that but they're
like like you ever get personally
offended when you go in a YouTube video
and then the comments are disabled like
II like something you never wanted to
comment on or you never yeah if it's
just most of it is like anime trailers
or anime opening sometimes I see the
comments that they say but I'm like I
don't know why but I feel offended are
you [ __ ]
I tend like American for like five seven
I'm like free speech
where's my second memory you know like
going back to what you said earlier with
the if if Yuri watch the sharing on the
right headspace yeah I just for some
reason I was like I'm pretty sure if I
rewatched darker than black
I wouldn't think it's that kind of a
show but I remember very well I remember
really liking this yeah
I'm happy to leave that memory like what
shows like that of that like oh go proxy
for me is one of those yeah I rewatched
I go proxy I don't think I'd like I
don't think I'd like it as much but when
I watched it I was in that like
perfectly writing steel like big brain
boy Moe was like yep there's there's a
lot of shows that I'm just leaving in
that bubble yeah I'm happy to talk about
these shows but I never want to rewatch
them no cuz like for me that what the
one big show for me is cutting a cut on
no Kyoukai yeah I watched it when I was
like in a really dark headspace I
watched this one with the blood sword no
that's not that's beyond the battery he
said beyond the boundary yeah I'm a cool
guy yeah it's a cool kind of Canada is
beyond the boundaries oh yeah what the
[ __ ] the Japanese title of yeah that's
the one with the pink haired girl in the
glasses it's about it's the one with the
assassin who yeah I was in a really dark
headspace when I watched that and no but
like it's it like it was one of those
series that's I don't want to be that
guy but it was like kind of
life-changing for me like because okay
now we need him there please please well
because like I was I was like I don't
wanna get too much in the detail but I
was like in a headspace that I was I
kind of like the lowest I've ever been
in my life and then I watched this
series and it connected me connected
with me on a level that's nothing else
could at the time and it kind of like
really changed my perception of the
world and everything like that and
because of this like one of my favorite
anime of all time but because I'm not in
the same head space that I am now that I
was back then I'm so [ __ ] terrified
of rewatching it because if I we watch
it and I just don't get that same
connection that I'm like III don't want
to lose that
I don't want to lose what that series
gave to me at that time at that time of
my life and that was that's that's like
the one series that I I really hold like
really close to me yeah and another
series is actually Evangelion because
Evangelion I I think is one show that
it's just infinitely rewatchable right
yeah every time that I've watched
Evangelion I've got a different
experience out of a hundred percent
agree I've watched it first time when it
came on Netflix first time I were
watching it I'd really how do you find
her it was good I mean I think because
it was the mega hype showed that it was
Mickey Cohen expecting too much
yeah yeah I mean I was I was happy with
what I what I got it was just very
confusing it was great and I liked how
he built the world is a very very
terrifying one and I feel like it's a
lot of animation struggle to do that
yeah and like a truly terrifying do you
have like that one anime that as Gahan
said is like life-changing for you yeah
yeah I I mean we spoke about it last
episode which [ __ ] up the recording
right right but yeah Bo Khurana is
definitely one of those shows that like
definitely changed yeah yeah cuz it was
again I think it was a similar thing
where I was at a point where I think I
was really confused with what I wanted
in my life yeah and it really helped
like ground me a lot and really
understand a lot of emotions that I was
perhaps feeling we can we talk about Bo
Corrado because I want the audience to
know but yeah it's one of those shows
where it's not the best sure but it's a
very important one that I think people
should watch yeah and I don't know how
to describe that's very eloquently
disturbing but not for like the
conventional reason for it being
disturbed yeah
so what Bo Carano is about is there's
this group of kids this is gonna sound
awesome by the way even Gillian Ripa
Veronica because there's these group of
kids and then the like I think we're on
this school trip or something school
trip yeah and then they find this all I
remember is they find his cave with a
talking head or something like no so
there's a guy in a cave and he's like a
middle-aged man working on like a PC
right it's really weird setup yeah and
he basically asked them do you want to
play a game would you like to play a
game
which you know anyone asking me that
ever with a bunch of kids in immediate
no name and then I think they all get on
a scale or something they all turns he
messes them and then you know they
whatever happens and suddenly they go
outside or happens later on in that
evening because they're all weave
kitchen know these characters a little
bit that's like how many kids is there
12 like 12 30 years something like that
around that many kids and then they get
teleported into this huge Mac and
there's a scary floating head that's
like talking to them and and one of the
children has to pilot the mech and now
we're gonna go into spoilers a little
bit but yeah it's it's episode one so
I'm gonna spoil the premise a little bit
to you but yeah so one of the kids
pilots the mech and they're fighting
another Mac and it's to save the world
then they're told
yes floating head character very
intimidating character so they win the
battle hurray they all win they all
celebrate and they go outside they stand
on the Mac and then one of the kids just
drops dead and falls off the Mac then
they find out that each time this mech
comes back and they're summoned one of
the kids has to pilot the mech and when
they do they're gonna die immediately
after yeah but it's to save the world
yeah and what the the real beauty of
this show isn't really the mech battles
or the mech fights it's more of the fact
that these kids who have to pilot the
mech to save the world like every is
like it's kept basically kind of like a
monster of the week on a show right
every week and you monster comes along
and the new kids and another kid from
that group has to pilot the mech but
it's about the backstory of each of the
kids and just having to deal with the
fact that they're gonna die yes they're
just gonna die and in like really
realistic ways as well like these
characters are very believable it makes
me like uncomfortable even like thinking
back to like the emotions that poured
out and me yeah they're like I get like
very like it's really really brutally
honest look into like the human
condition and yeah life and especially
how it's you know a lot of these kids
from a lot of different backgrounds some
of them have it easier I remember
there's a one kid who's the
stereotypical piece of [ __ ] but there's
some of the kids you know who I think
there's one kid who's like 16 or
whatever nice looking after two is two
siblings yeah and it's brutal because
this he's the one who's raising these
two his two sisters I think yeah
and it's horrible seeing him after like
come to terms with that he's not gonna
better look after his sister it's rude
it's something that just disturbs you
unlike a level that you can't really do
it's so raw it's so realistic yeah you
know filters yeah whatsoever I'm like
it's it's something that already was
like not many people have watched it's
it's something I was really good
uncomfortable it's really uncomfortable
have to like sit down and sit through
III admit I definitely like did not
watch it when I was first came out like
I definitely gave us some time yo cuz I
cuz I think the problem with boquerón on
the reason why so many people didn't
watch it when it came I was because the
way that they marketed it was not that
good not that angle like oh it's a mecca
must just be in a tank yelling rip off
there's no world where it's like the
number one anime because it's just too
uncomfortable yeah yeah but it also came
out in the time period cuz I think it
was like the early to mid-2000s it
wasn't where there was just so many
Evangelion ripple eyes and like they
they're of like varying quality as well
there's another show that I [ __ ] love
as well which is rahxephon
oh that's good that's just the revine
gilliam cool it's a ripoff but it's
still really good it's it's really it's
really good it's like it totally rips
off but it goes about it in a totally
different way from the Evangel yeah yeah
and boqueron oh also sits in this
category of just shows that people
really looked over cuz premise alone
sounds like an Evangelion room it does
it does but the way the way they go
about it is just absolutely harrowing
just seeing these stories of these kids
who have to come to terms with their own
mortality because it's a [ __ ] tragedy
you know I mean it's different from even
get even Gilly one to me is just a nose
raw cry for help
you know what I mean that's like you
can't watched like everyone's analyzed
the last two episodes of Evangelion and
I I I think it's I think it's going back
to that meme about the blue cut I'm
[ __ ] sure that I know had no [ __ ]
clue everyone's like oh okay the way
that these lines move and the way that
it's like very sketchy is like really
reflective of Shinji's like mental state
meanwhile I know it's just like we
didn't have much of a budget just just
want to put back fairly because because
like like but that's why I love that
you've an kalium
everyone come everyone comes out of even
getting on with something different
because his message was so raw and he
put so much for himself into the series
that it's impossible not to like come
out with it feeling something with even
Gillian especially that I don't know if
it's just uh no is just like trolling
like crazy but there were moments where
like the Evangelion fanbase and like the
the like super hardcore
analysts of Evangelion I like just so
committed to this idea of like
everything and even gaily on every piece
of imagery everything has to have a
meaning there I remember when uh no
finally came out in an interview about
like the meaning behind Evangelion and
it just straight-up said there is no
meaning it's just the show I wanted to
make and people like but what about like
the fact that every time the Angels die
it turns into a cross and he's like I
thought that looked cool and all the
analysts like no no he's lying
yeah it has to be a meaning behind I'm
like if the creator says there's no
meaning what is no meaning what's
Occam's razor where the simplest
simplest solution is the best solution
normally the the actual sleep yeah yeah
yeah and it's like it even goin
definitely made me uncomfortable and
feel bad for a lot of the characters
yeah like boqueron are just just would
like I mean I'd say like even Gideon
isn't from like a story it's it's not
it's not even remotely similar boqueron
Oh like I feel like has more of a
structure around its plots where you
think anyone just you ended on this you
know as I said Rourke rifle for help
from Anna yeah but Bo Khurana was
definitely here's here's a group of kids
dealing with something that's very very
uncomfortable and you're gonna feel fun
or for work and it's like it's not even
the worst part that like kids are gonna
die it's like sometimes it's their
[ __ ] back stories of [ __ ] horrific
yeah and I'm not gonna say it's a little
spoiler Lex it's really at all but that
was one episode in particular and uh it
like after I finished it was one of the
things I had to like just sit there for
like five minutes and be like [ __ ] like
I don't know if you can remember all the
episode there's one a few plots that
like one of the stories are ours just
like
Yeah right at the end you think that you
expected everything right yeah that's
what I love though about these like
human drama shows is that like sometimes
they may just be like the simplest thing
of like just a story between two people
yeah one person but if it's done really
[ __ ] well it can be some of the most
powerful [ __ ] storytelling yeah well
I think it's more relatable than at most
things and it's really uncomfortable to
think that you could be in a situation
where you have to come to terms with
your death that's why that's why I like
you know I'll say this till the end of
time believe that's the whole reason why
my favorite manga artist of all time is
any asana I was I was gonna say the one
series that the one manga series that
I'm like that I'm still waiting on to be
in the right headspace to read is oh yes
me boy yeah I've read that I've reread
that like two or three times like all
the way through and every time I'm just
like oh no the only way it's just oh no
yeah because it's just so like and it's
not just pinpoint as well like any other
Sanne is just so good at writing these
characters that are just so believable
yeah and it's really disturbing when you
see these characters these very
believable characters run into these
very believable and horrifying
situations and you're just like this is
like based off like a real person's life
and that's just scary in and of itself
because this guy can just think of stuff
like this yeah yeah and present it in a
way that is just so terrifying I think
it's like when people like man
danganronpa is really like despair for
please shut the it's got pink blood for
[ __ ] bag like like real despair is like
uncomfortable pissed off so many Duncan
Rouleau fans don't you see these
characters like they're about to die
down it's like oh the [ __ ] gives a [ __ ]
yes cuz I feel like there are certain
levels cuz like everything though ever
the series that we've talked about is
just like it hits you I know I don't
want to say it but like it hits
different
okay - a reason why you should watch
this if you'll like me I'm a person who
avoids these kind of shares like the why
cuz I cryed like anything I cry out like
deku when he says anything in my ear
academic but my deku screams even like a
little bit I'm like I'm in tears I don't
know why it's like a human reaction I'll
cry of anything so I know means what
shows that I can tell my brain often
yeah I don't want to have to get into
like oh [ __ ] sake I'm really scared now
I really just like what now that you've
said that I really want you to read like
any new a son no I know I know it's
gonna bruise it and that's why like I I
stay away from it but like please watch
Bo Crowder you know it's if you're in
the right headspace for that kind of
show cause like you know you know when
you have like social barriers up and
yeah yeah you see something that's
senior sad or something it's like it's
like yeah you feel sad you cry whatever
but there are some shows that you like
you don't know whether you want to cry
or but or you lie down and just like
disappear yeah yeah cuz there's plenty
of romance shows that like you've really
mmm
left me kind of like very sad but it's a
different feeling like it's all
different field and week made me very
sad a lot of the time so it's called
golden we go to time in time a golden
time sorry yeah I'm an egg um III like
golden time alot maybe very sad you know
very upset a lot of time but like it's
it's just like it it's not I don't leave
that feeling like oh man there's no hope
anymore III felt the same way when I
watch soccer osa as well because like
there are some coz like that seems like
all like oh yeah you know cute you know
kids in a room you know just yeah but
some of the back stories of some of
these characters I'm just like [ __ ] man
describe [ __ ] man that's just it's a sad
dude but yeah as you said it's not like
it's sadness and despair are just two
totally different emotions right cuz cuz
it's kind of like those kinds of shows
where you know I used the oh it changed
my life kind of kind of which is really
corny when you say it yeah but it's just
one of those shows when you finish and
you just sit down and you just like
staring at a blank Warren you're like
yeah
it's that big scientist you can't even
like listen to the ending song so I
can't listen to being silenced right now
like I remember being very sad and
having a similar feeling watching Bojack
horseman and it taps in the same areas I
know you're laughing by the way last
last last time we recorded this I said
an analogy we're amazing Carano right to
sum it up to you if you're familiar with
Bojack horseman Bo Khurana is imagine if
Bojack horseman had 12 kids and they
were all equally as [ __ ] up as Bo
Jackson and then and then they all had
to get sacrificed and you slowly got to
hear the backstory of these fucked-up
Bojack horseman and the children it's so
[ __ ] up and it's it's it's like
different because in Bojack it's his own
fault right and yeah and it whatever
it's very very sad okay well it hits
this episode of trash taste is sponsored
by expressvpn Wow we've changed shirts
Jerry how amazing I'm here to tell you
today about expressvpn now I'm sure a
lot of your thinking
I caught up how you think of me to merge
the FBI can't see me and you'd be wrong
in thinking well call me out like this
corner me wrong it doesn't save you
only expressvpn can save you and your
browsing history as a lot of these
websites can still see your browsing
history or your internet service
provider can see what websites you're
visiting because of your IP address and
honestly that's why I never go online
without expressvpn also the good thing
about expressvpn is that you can bypass
geo restrictions so say for example I
want to go onto Netflix and watch I
don't know
Harry Potter but it's not available on
Japanese Netflix so what do I do
I tap on expressvpn i rerouted to the US
Netflix and boom there it is all of
Harry Potter because sometimes I don't
want to watch anything I want to watch
some goddamn hair good thing is if it
doesn't matter if you're on Verizon or
Comcast or whatever ISP you're on
expressvpn will hide all the information
and all the traffic that routes through
your router from them so even the ISPs
can't see your browsing history and the
thing is it runs so smoothly that most
of the time you don't even realize that
you have expressvpn on and the best
thing is expressvpn is available on all
devices of
the computer mobile phones tablets you
name it so you can protect your online
internet safety today by using the
number one rated VPN service out there
by going to expressvpn comm / trash
taste to get three months free off of
your subscription that's expr ESS VPN
comm / trash taste yes I'm reading this
from my phone just in case I get the
spelling wrong expressvpn comm / trash
taste - line more links in the
description below
back to the video cuz I think one other
series that I watched that just hit like
really deep is this for like for episode
ova based on this novel called no longer
human which is like a classic Japanese I
all summer yeah yeah yeah that is like
it's probably one of the most harrowing
things that I've watched never heard
about that what is it rights what it's
written by this guy called docile summer
who is consider like one of the three
greats okay traditional Japanese
literature he was like a guy for the big
three what's the story on this one um
it's like it's been a while since I've
watched it but I'm not sure if it's his
like water biography or if it's like
based on his life story but it's just
based on his life style okay so it's
just based on this life story about this
guy who just who just keeps taking
Elle's man like imagining four days take
imagine if you just take elves your
entire life and you're just looking for
that one win but no you just you just
you just keep taking LS your entire life
and it sounds like the Joker it's it's
this guy just gets more and more
depressed as his life goes on because -
it is based on his life story so like
this character it's someone who's like
clinically depressed you know and he's
so depressed that's you know he tries
taking his life multiple times I were
with with you know woman that he's been
with or just people that he finds and
then he just he just keeps living which
which is actually true like the author
tried committing suicide one or several
times and then he succeeded yeah he
actually succeeded so that's round
himself yeah so that's like the
headspace of the author who wrote this
and like it's like it's this the story's
like I can't wait so he died yeah yeah
he finished after finishing
this door that he finished this was the
last novel here oh yeah yeah so it's
just [ __ ] it's the most like it's
like one long suicide no then yeah yeah
yes cuz it's just like a raw peek into
the headspace of someone's is almost
depressing absolutely good that's a
really good piece yeah because like it's
it's it's just this it's just based on
his life story and all the shitty things
that happens to him and then it ends
with just you you think that you think
he's found like of this ray of hope
right you think he's he's fine his ray
of hope and then he just gets [ __ ] on
once again like imagine if someone has
stage 4 leukemia and then you just find
out he has AIDS as well and then he gets
kicked on and then you just kick on it
kick him while he was going yeah and
like how it ends is that he's like he's
like so like he he doesn't even think
that died like if he commits suicide
that's not even the right way to end it
it's called no longer human because he
feels like he's so he's so low that he
just doesn't he's no longer human
like he's no he's no longer is in this
human world and it is the most harrowing
thing I've used harrowing a lot because
I don't know I don't know why I mean the
only way to describe the tone I don't
know if you you're essentially reading
the default right yeah yeah that's that
sounds like yeah yeah it's it's brutal
it's the only way to describe it I mean
I I like those experiences but they are
like you said over there you have to be
in the right headspace because I feel
like if you go into it like already like
pretty [ __ ] up like you're not feeling
too great
it's yes talking to do great for your
mental I think I think the one problem
is well with no longer human and the
reason why probably not a lot of people
late know about it yeah is that not just
because of its like subject matter but
just the fact that anime fans today know
does I or some movie for that one boom
go stray dogs character like a people
like oh does I yeah he was my husband Oh
in bingo stray dogs not knowing that the
real does I was the most depressed
[ __ ] over in like all of Japanese
literature and he wrote some not just no
longer human but he writes a
amazing pieces of literature yeah just
because again he based it so much on his
real life in the fact that he was just
[ __ ] depressed as hell yeah and it's
cause like I feel like you have to be in
the head space to write something that
powerful is that raw that just hits and
just cuts that deeply it's like an Edgar
Allan Poe situation yeah yeah like you
can't write dark poetry like that unless
you had a [ __ ] up life growing up
sorry sorry to bring a downer of this
episode people watch bottom line is that
you know regardless of the fact that we
did like talk about a lot of light
depressing pieces of literature and
media like just because it like puts you
down at the end of the day it doesn't
mean it's something that people should
skip over I think that it's equally as
important to experience those kinds of
I'm anime and I like to do that so that
I'm comfortable with having those
emotions prop up sometimes right yeah
that I can I feel like I haven't be some
experience dealing with them maybe when
it's someone else is a lot easier but if
you do get to that point where you are
starting to feel like that it's like
okay I can I understand where this is
coming from yeah yeah maybe I know
better how to processor
yeah like question to you guys going off
this then but it's a bit less depressing
has there been any shows or any anime in
your in your history that has like
affected you in any way not just like
not just like in the negative aspect
obviously or just rethinking I would
just like black but I think me like the
one as much as I hate to use the word
change my life for me was like and this
is gonna sound cliche as [ __ ] but
Clannad was one I totally understand
when I laughed it comes from I know
there was a handful of people who
laughed at the same time right because
it's so cliche now to say that climate
change I play when I watch that like all
the way through it like straight up cuz
that was not a story [ __ ] me out that
was the first time that I'd like in not
just an enemy but in any piece of media
then I just [ __ ] broke
yeah yeah because especially that second
half of Clannad after story it was just
the most brutal power yeah those two the
longest build-up right and just I don't
think I'll be able to that's again like
going back like milling topics that's
another show I don't think I'll be able
to watch again
yeah just because again I'm not in that
headspace and it's just something it's
not just like the fact that it was just
a sad anime but I think it's just the
fact that again you've been kind of
following these characters lives all the
way through where like where as like
most you know visual novels or like
romance stories would end with the
couple getting together yeah why med
took that one step further and showed
you as the title says the after story
right of like what happens and I think
just seeing that made these characters
even more relatable to me and that was
the first time where I was like you know
what family family is cool man like
family's [ __ ] door like before that
family was just like a Christian man
like you know concept of like family was
just very much like everybody else was
like yeah of course family's cool like
yeah everyone wants a family
but like Clan that was that one show
that really dug into like just how
important family is and I think that
like I mean as weird as it is to say
after I watch Clannad I became way close
to my family and I think that's like a
be pretty wholesome that just it is
wholesome and I'm like and that like
really changed my life I feel really bad
now cuz you're talking about how can I
change your life I couldn't [ __ ]
finish the first thing yeah and after
saw yeah and I said oh the whole time
I'm watching cloud I'm like when's it
gonna get good I am don't [ __ ] sing
that dango song I dare you to sing that
song cuz like I remember watching the
first eight episodes and I'm just like
this this is trying really hard it's
very boring yes but that's the problem
right is that like the thing was the
first season of Clan I never say to
people hey you should watch the first
season recliner yeah because I know that
on the grand scale of things the first
season [ __ ] appreciate the second season
that's the problem you can't jump into
off the story without having experienced
these characters yeah
and it is important because a lot of
these characters do make a very
significant impact in after story but I
guess you know it's really hard I guess
especially now like baby back then you
could make so much 25 episodes yeah yeah
[ __ ] to get a good payoff but now
you can't do that I just don't think you
can recommend dirty right because like
the the story structure and the joke
structures that help in it's just so
overdone now that laying down it just
seems like an aged version of everything
that you can see today but back when
Klein I first came out in like 2009 I
believe yeah that's about 2007 mm what
are you choosing me or the first season
I remember thinking like this is just
like shittier a school dynamic which is
garbage do you just watch every high
school and a man just like yeah it's in
high school yeah it's the same I like to
compare the high school animes since you
won't like dynamics they got going on
and see what all the uniform is
difference okay I like going off topic
like I remember the first time I watched
Sarah from the end and I remember it was
like it was like a show with a
post-apocalyptic show right about like
how vampires had taken over the world
yeah and then for like four episodes in
there's just a [ __ ] high school and
I'm like well why is there a high school
that if there's one show that doesn't
need a high school dynamic [ __ ] this
show I'm like guilty cuz like I'm like
the only guy I think you read is read
like all of that manga so far lizards
don't know I'm the complete opposite
guilty I've never consumed anything
about it which is so weird because for
the longest time I don't know if you
guys got these messages so many people
were asking me to make a video right
it's got a really big female fault yeah
yeah yeah you notice I don't think
there's been a single an achiever that's
made a video on it cuz we use they're
all because they're all dudes you
females we have the first episode of
zeref the end was like I wanted like the
best first episodes yeah I remember for
a while the we'd had is such a good
first episode in the Rye not even the
lines really good world ending Wars and
then at Yale except high school
it gets really good again when they
leave high school it does quickly
abandoned man I'd like to think that's
the artist the other author being like
yes it got really good and I'd say well
like about two-thirds through the manga
because I hasn't finished yet but about
two-thirds for the manga artist right
now it gets amazing yeah and then it
goes like not so good yeah cuz did the
manga deviate from the anime because I
remember watching all of the anime and
it's it was one of those shows where I
had a good time watching it if I
remember correctly the manga was really
really similar to the show right and
they build on a lot of the things that I
thought were really interesting on the
show amazingly in the in the manga as it
goes on yeah but then it became really
weird and world ending what kind of like
trigger II Ryan it's yeah I don't really
like the main main like the final
villain that they have as well it's just
a fine it's fine
it's is one of those shows where I'm
like I had a good time watching you I'm
not gonna really watch it I'm probably
not gonna remember most would you
recommend people to read it or watch it
because I haven't done either yeah if
you I would say watch it and if you like
what you watched and continue onwards
okay I'm gonna probably enjoy it I think
yeah okay up to a certain point and then
you'll start to be like confused and
it's good there it's good I like how
they did a lot of things and like the
much Trump said in seventh I like how
they did things I like the things I did
I totally get it because I actually
agree view like oh yeah it was good IIIi
had a good time it's it's like it's like
the most six out of ten ever it's like
it's it's very decent and I have no
minimal complaints yeah there's not much
to it and you're just kind of like I'm
happy I'm happy with what happened I
don't want anymore it was before I had
like five II sakai to watch every season
but and this is took the space of that
when this came after right after the
hyper-v someone attack yeah yeah I
remember everyone was Hyper's fought for
this and yeah and
like so off even though I thought about
the alley was pretty [ __ ] high
yeah just kind of just it just didn't
take off and I don't know why that's it
right it is well because the anime had
like an amazing like fight scene it like
yeah like a like an orchestrated like
fight like they were hunting down these
vampires really cool episode and for
some reason that wasn't enough it's one
of those shows that weirdly like I hear
some people talk about talk about but I
don't really see anything about you know
what I mean yeah because I think people
who read it are really really into it
yeah yeah it's good I think the problem
with it is that I just kind of liked its
own identity when it first aired because
I remember when it first night I think
like I made a joke that I was like oh
it's like a taco and blue exes with gay
vampires very much is like an
amalgamation of a lot of different
aspects yeah yeah and the main character
is kind of annoying yeah that's true as
well that's never good it's annoying
because it's like I like all of this
we're getting a lot of this one thing
that I'm just kind of wish would just be
a little less like potent you know yeah
yeah there's a lot of shows like that
there where I've read the manga after it
and no one really spoke about it and I
was like I don't really know I like a
certain black clover
like low I didn't repay man hey man
black clover is good I'm repping black
go off for 40 minutes about it my monkey
brains like taking over now some reason
I always end up reading the manga that
no one [ __ ] talks about or gives a
[ __ ] about and I don't know why I think
cuz because I don't know anything I find
it more interesting because no one told
I'm definitely in that phase right now
yeah I'm just like I just want to find
the weirdest [ __ ] like unknown manga
and just like talk about okay like I
know that I know it's not unknown at all
but I read terraformers just because
like no one speaks about it and I
remember liking what I saw of the anime
which like is the anime adaptation was
horrible or but I remember enjoying the
concept so I went back and read all of
it I had a [ __ ] great time yeah their
form is also amazing you should
definitely read it if you get the chance
super gory terrifying cockroaches yeah
great time really good if you've seen
the thumbnail that Connor is made about
his cockroach story that that's a
terraform a [ __ ] well let me give you
like a 30-second pitch right on
terraform is sir.you these as an
expedition to Mars and as these
cockroaches
that are like absolute Giga Chad
Cochrane like the most but like Jim bro
cockroaches and then they want to bring
them back to earth to see why they're
like this who made these cockroaches
like this because there must be
something and then they then it turns
out that yo these guys can fight and
then the humans get injected with an bug
DNA insect DNA to become superhumans but
then they still keep getting destroyed
by the Giga Chad cockroaches and it's
just a great war it's a great time in
politics lots of game of throne politics
ask things involved yeah it's fantastic
lots of deaths yeah it's great because
you would think that a really
straightforward plot way it's about
action big cockroach fight big bug boy
yeah and but then it's just certainly
but then it really quickly why you you
big boy because you'll never feel as
excited for learning one bug like cuz I
remember right I remember thinking when
I was in like high school the mantis
shrimp coolest bug in the world the
mantis shrimp is is that he's not the
one that like pun they can punch it like
the speed of sound oh yeah it punches so
hard that it can't be contained and
aquarium this thing is like like yeah
yeah and then when they made like a
human formed with a mantis shrimp out he
was our P but uh I've gone off topic but
because I remember think you you read
like a vide any chapters of this thing
thinking that it's just gonna be like
big man punch bug man like you down
Fripp then it quickly turns into like
the weight if f was trying to take over
Mars and get these samples there would
be a lot of [ __ ] up politics involved
with what your country is gonna want
yeah yeah yeah and so it devolves into a
lot of that it's really [ __ ]
interests wall buildings done really
[ __ ] super [ __ ] good
I really recommend it sorry they've
turned from a 30-second pitch into a
full discussion but there's a great
manga and if you if you like something
like dance something like that yeah boy
I feel right at home for you yeah I
think I've rented just after I read guns
cuz I was looking for something very low
effect for that kind of yeah I was in
the I was in like that edgy teenager
phase
I resisted living my edgy teenager face
like six months ago I read yes I read
terraformers like yo sometimes sometimes
the edgy teenager phase like you never
grow out of it you know I I [ __ ] love
going back to my edgy teenager phase cuz
I I really want to reread Gant's as well
ganses [ __ ] great that's like that
defines what I was into as like as like
a late teen it's like really it's a sexy
girls cool yeah when he starts just like
okay this is scenic dance and like I
guess we sure used to the normal
dynamics in anime yeah rather like a hot
girl turns up and he wants to have sex
with her but then he actually just start
the [ __ ] [ __ ] you know I'm like who
is this Chad like I've never seen such a
big child in animated Oh what the [ __ ] I
was on the train reading this as well
there's a terrible manga to read on the
trains every time I flick the panel or
just be naked tits yeah it's so weird
that it's like not even remotely like a
realistic depiction of it's so because
then suddenly she's obsessed with him
after it's yeah but the one thing that's
amazing about gansan and I could I would
like to sell people on is one the
monster drawings and the same do not
want you do not want to watch the I know
what that's awfully good because Gantz
is like like peak mid-2000 gonzo CG it's
like you think CG today's bad watch
watch Ganz and you just see how bad CG
was back there so remember the I just
absolutely just messed up CG of like
even the opening is like let's see how
many times we can rotate this camera
heads we make everybody sick hopefully
have it on screen right now so you can
suppose you'd saw everything was a
[ __ ] banging oh that song was so good
my rip slime a drip signed by every time
I watched it I was like I'm about to
throw up
it's so amazing if you enjoyed the good
parts of darling in the Franks like the
mystery and not knowing anything about
the world and wondering like oh my god
how does this all function yeah if you
like that aspect of world building your
love dance yeah I was really impressed
by the world building in Gant's because
not not to spoil how it ends but like
the actual ending of Gans itself was
like very very antique
questionable but the actual answers was
like that that kind of like that wasn't
kind of like that you know that big
brain like me felt like oh my god like
it it's [ __ ] great like it's one of
the few series that I've seen that has
built up this huge mystery and has
delivered on it and has delivered on an
answer though that like I said it's
satisfying the actual ending is not
great but the answers for the main
mysteries were very satisfying
yeah and amazingly yeah the explanation
for all the stuff that was happening is
very cool yeah and I thought it's really
interesting but there's also some stuff
in the manga everybody's read it will
know what I mean there's a part where
like a character does blackface and
suddenly like - oh my god I completely
forgot six months ago and that's like a
scene where one of the characters goes
to shoot up a thing in public goes to do
a public shooting that's oh my god now
though it's like really breathe at all
that is the most don't cancel
it's like the it's a normal Japanese guy
and then he wears black face but then he
just is drawn like an actual black guy
yeah and it's really really unkind yeah
yes you're like and then that was the
moment where I went online you like this
is anyone else realized how [ __ ] up it
and they immediately everyone was like
we you know it's good but we kind of
turnable
it's the one thing that makes it really
hard to recommend because it's a very
interesting series and that does a lot
of cool things but then it's really
really [ __ ] like that part is like
yeah you could recommend it to edge
people yeah yeah yeah it's just too much
it's just it's just like a example of
something that hasn't aged well because
I when I've read that as a kid I think
you know there's a lot of nuance that is
lost a Japanese called yeah yeah it's
still even for Japanese standards is
pretty awful it was like when Gant's was
like serializing
it was very like lopsided in terms of
like is not I care if the Japanese
audience is concerned with it being
racist yes like it's it's like it was
like it's definitely the one giant stain
on like Gantz in general I think so
other than 3d CG that's a pretty damn
thing I mean that's just the stain
that's just like the [ __ ] stain on the
I'm a Hannah live-action movie didn't
they yeah but the live-action was not as
horrible as a lot of people thought it
was going to because I watched the live
action and I was like it wasn't amazing
late solid 5 out of tango but yeah
there's definitely a lot of like
questionable CG about it because of
course Japanese live-action is Lee right
but the way that they actually like did
the whole Gant's thing in the whole feel
of it the flag the whole like despair of
like oh [ __ ] this wall we don't know
what the [ __ ] is having yeah it's not
really well in the live-action what do
you think is like the best live-action
animated movie cuz that's hard one is
for you
Gintama oh yeah a live-action I was I've
never laughed that hard watching a live
action and late not even like I'm not
talking about like Dragonball Evolution
like ironic laughing like it's genuinely
funny thief it's genuine it brings out
the Gintama spirit so [ __ ] well and I
don't know how the hell they did it
because you read a Mongol against i'ma
watch anime like in telling you like
there's no way this can be live-action
yeah no [ __ ] way Lee you can't
translate this comedy into live-action
but they somehow did it lad to do it I'm
like the casting was perfect the Cossack
your tricks I've no idea even the action
scenes because the second half of it
goes into like the first story arc of
Gandia yeah and concludes it and I'm
like wow this is actually like really
good CG really good choreography and
it's like very believable Gintama be
like I would watch that again that's how
good I was pleasantly surprised with the
Jojo part for maybe really it was like I
didn't like him yeah he was like fine I
didn't like some of the scenes that are
pretty good I mean that's that's that's
the thing it was live-action anime
movies right the bar is so low that just
yeah listen is it good
it's all of these other [ __ ] morosely
being passable is like the best
compliment you can give an anime
live-action I remember watching the
ghost in the shell' live action and I
remember how offensively average it was
yeah like it was like like like I
couldn't form an opinion in there cuz
I'm just like it's okay it's like it the
ghost in the shell' was really weird
because it's like if you watched it as a
ghost in the show live-action it was
like a four out of ten yeah but if you
just watched it it's like if you just
thought like okay this is just a
standalone like sci-fi complex you know
I wish Aleta the battle angel was like
really good and you told I forget that's
a yeah I think that's one of the best
that I like anime or manga movies we've
had really I mean it was the ending was
just whack but I mean everything up
until the ending for me Aleta was very
much like goes in the show whereas like
as I put it higher than ghosts in this
you have you read Aleta why I watch the
show he's read everything that's why
I've watched the movie right yeah I
guess I bet if I watch the manga I'd
like yeah very much like ghosts in the
show eat them hug haha but I read the
manga I'd appreciate but I'd like the
moan room if you it's like goes on the
show right like people who are fans of
ghosts on the show before there was live
action were like that was a [ __ ]
adaptation of goes on the show yeah
Elite is the exact same as good as a
standalone movie but as an adaptation of
a leader it was pretty weak but at least
at least the Hollywood ones are better
than their Japanese being like Nazis I
got invited by madman in Australia as
you go to the cinemas on the date like
you can bring a plus-one so I brought my
best friend quite a huge anime fan and
we watched it and we just kind of sat
there as the credits were rolling and I
just looked around like how was that my
friends like I know you got me in for
free but I want my money I'm like you
know I kind of have to agree with you
there man right no because I like my
cousin who I've been trying to get into
an life like ages biggest Norma you can
kind of think of and then I was working
there
like I was like I was like recommitting
attack on Titan because that's like one
of the perfect game yeah yeah its attack
on Titan and then he [ __ ] ends up
watching the attack on Titan live-action
and he is like yeah that wasn't very
good I'm like why why oh you were almost
there you are this close and now like
now whenever I recommend attack when
tight I'm like no no no trust me the
anime is so much better he's like oh
like is it the same story but like yeah
yeah hey my son no but there's this
character called Levi he wasn't in the
live-action because they couldn't
pronounce his name oh really the reason
why Levi is not in the live-action is
because they were like these are
Japanese actors I don't think they can
pronounce the V sound and I'm like you
don't realize this was written by a
Japanese oh yeah yeah people like that
the reason why microwaves come with
instructions they need a hand to hold
the [ __ ] movie stay away from the
movies though I say from all our movies
I think the only one I should enjoy it
is edge of tomorrow which I didn't have
one was really good Tom Cruise Tom
Cruise Tom Hanks out yeah I didn't
really cuz I didn't even realize that
was based on a manga yeah all you need
is kill just like the edgiest title ever
yeah all you need is kill all you can
see it's actually based off a novel that
was later adapted into a manga that was
written by about the takishi Oh Oh
straight for death night right right
right yeah which is also very good manga
well so when I saw cuz like I picked up
the novel walls in Japan because I was
just like all you need to secure [ __ ]
yeah dude that's awesome and I read it
and the novel is really good but then
like when they were promoting in the
bookstore they were like Tom Cruise
movie coming out soon I was just like oh
no oh don't be one please please Tom
don't do this but of course I had to go
watch because I'm like alright this is
gonna be pretty it's probably gonna be
[ __ ] let's go watch it was like oh good
I'll give you this one Holly was good
you didn't do it you do it was it was
one of the few
I watched it and I was like oh I gotta
go read the source material now and it
was quite different from the source
material wasn't exactly the same but
that's how you adapt a live-action movie
in my opinion gonna change some things
if there is something that is just if
there's a concept in a story that you
know will never work in live-action
don't put it in yeah it's so simple and
yet there are so many [ __ ]
productions and directors who are like
oh we can do it yeah we definitely
assassination classroom giant yellow guy
[ __ ] man CG we'll fix that is a weird
adaptation I I don't know why but I've
slowly started to find myself like
watching live action anime movies why
would you do this to your thing cuz it's
just gonna give me [ __ ] watching trashy
secure huh it's just a guilty pleasure
for me now even if it's because I watch
the erase live-action as well and even
though I didn't like erased Len that was
on Netflix right yeah but purely just
because I was like oh it's it's just
it's it's the puffy example of curiosity
killed the cat right because it's like
I'm so curious to be like this how could
they possibly adapt this and then I go
into it I'm like amazing I just wasted
an hour and a half just some anime
adaptions you just know we're gonna be
[ __ ] yeah there's some you watch for the
train wreck but not all of them like
oratio need to watch The Full Metal
Alchemist live-action I don't need to
watch that to know it's gonna be [ __ ]
yeah that's the one I that's the one
thing I still haven't you know I'm gonna
do guys alchemist isn't that good [ __ ]
you talk talks for Metallica miss sucks
what we guys on in the story yeah run
story it's just awful I mean the only
reason I watch The Death Note one is cuz
you know wow I know I wanted to be you
know able to help with the discussion on
Twitter and then oh yeah yeah yeah I
mean I got a great video out of it but
if you call it yeah exactly right you
can clown on it it's great cuz
everyone's gonna be waiting for it yeah
you can't clown the already strong
because no one gives a [ __ ] well that's
why I didn't make a video of you well I
watch you while they sit down
hi-y I mean I've done that I've done
that with more I think there are more
anime live actions that I haven't made a
video on than ones that I have made a
video on just because no one needs to
know this is [ __ ] I just need to know
this because everybody already knows
it's [ __ ] like I didn't have to make a
video on the parasite live action
because everybody knew was gonna be [ __ ]
but I needed to know that it was gonna
be [ __ ] and sure enough and I found out
that it was absolutely gone
you don't blows my mind that sometimes
they may only make the anime to promote
the garbage movie yeah like with
parasite one of those situations I know
Kaiji The Gambler one yeah that was
definitely that anime was just made to
promote the movie yeah yeah and the
movie with Ali I actually like I enjoyed
the kaiju movie in this like really can
peek on away you know I mean it's kind
of but in what world would you choose
the movie over the anime oh no
absolutely not
right because like watching watching the
Kaiji live-action was kind of just
watching like some you know k drama or j
drama so you want to show work ideas
quickly so V yes so it's it's it's it's
a gambling what it's a gambling story so
this guy racks up this massive massive
debt I forgot what why he backed up this
massive debts oh come on why did her for
some reason yeah so so basically he gets
an offer from this like mysterious
company that can that can clear his debt
that just says you need to go on the
ship and you're gonna play a bunch of
games and you if you win these games
then we will clear your debts or you can
go into even greater depth yeah yeah and
the basic premise is just Kaiji on the
ship or just like after after the ship
Hawkes over it's just him going through
a bunch of different gambling games and
just trying to clear his debts and and
he's not Opie so that's like the best
part yes genuinely he loses a lot very
much as he wears and it's great because
you generally don't know if he's gonna
lose a winner yeah it's a very quotable
job it's really a lot of watch it I
think mainly because for some reason it
was only published in 480p really yeah
yeah yeah he was only published yeah it
came out in 2000
as well it was only 480p and I remember
like when I was watching him like West
was what's this like so just know that
when you watch it it's gonna be like
that but it's definitely worth your time
I thought the reason why people didn't
watch car shows because of the art style
I think is that and I think um I think
there's a ton of reasons why because
like it's got like zero female
characters in there I think yeah I can't
remember a single - got a lot of ugly
bastards that's cozy right imagine
imagine an NCR plot but instead of sex
it's just watching a guy it's just
gambling
it's just NCR gambling that's just crazy
okay but it's [ __ ] great so good I'm
going from watching Kaiji to I don't
know how you pronounce it caca guru it
was like how can I watch this [ __ ] when
this gambling is so fake
oh yeah yeah it's all just [ __ ]
gambling to serve the plot so I was in
Chi Chi it felt like real gamble it was
just like this through if they were like
okay how do we make these hot girls
orgasm yeah gambling let's just throw it
like the main character always wins
unless it doesn't really matter then she
doesn't win and it's like haha you
didn't expect well that's like yeah but
it didn't matter
like yeah exactly it's like like there
was a one dumb moment that's apart I
dropped the series when the girl with
the gun playing Russian roulette and
it's like it's obvious no one is going
to die in this situation don't pretend
like someone is going to die because I'm
not stupid
yeah and then I couldn't watch it
further somebody this is just dumb
whereas if that wasn't IG well it's like
someone's gonna die yeah which is great
because but then it wasn't sure maybe
both of them could die we don't here
that's the best part about Chi Chi is
that like you just genuinely don't know
the melodic IG is the narrator's voice
oh yeah why is that why is that just
that narrator in like every [ __ ] show
of that time because you know epic I
lost I already see it's an anime you
know you eating like you know watch you
this Netflix show this narrator comes
out you know a nude what's the follow-up
series the spin-off one with the middle
management whatever tonegawa
it's very it's quite funny it's if you
go in expecting kaity you're gonna be
very disappointed yes if you want if you
want kaisi then you it's better if you
read lie
I don't know the author's name but like
read some of his other works akagi's
really good a car key I really like a
car key was a car keys basically mahjong
chi-ji yeah I'm like here's the thing I
had no [ __ ] interest in mahjong I was
watching the show I had no [ __ ] rules
of the I had no [ __ ] clue of the
rules mahjong either yeah when you get
drawn in right after I finish I'll call
girls like me exact same thing I don't
know which show was use little girls
competing in mahjongg tournaments I
don't know which I think it was Mac
might have just been called mahjong no I
don't know what it Wallace I remember I
was trying my god damn pass to learn
mahjong and I was like I I mean like you
know mas comes in like a lion made me
really invested in shogi I was like yeah
I don't know what the [ __ ] shogi is but
then after I watch much comes on like I
want to learn show I mean show uses
Japanese chess er I don't even know how
to play chess and yet I was like sure
you look boy I'd play chess Jerri
because I just did it Wow we didn't even
own like a chess board my house you know
to play chess right yeah I know the
basics that's good [ __ ] sock it if
I'm playing weight a chess anime but of
seekers no because I I actually really
want a chess on amigo chance you'd be so
good a Nana might be so [ __ ] - I'm
surprised there hasn't been one year
because like how big is chair how big is
chess in Japan isn't it's not very big I
mean I guess if you're gonna play chess
you know it's there's plenty of knocks I
think a lot of the grandmasters are from
Japan oh yeah that's true actually but
like yeah I feel like chess because I
remember I go like sucked into this
YouTube hole of just like watching a lot
of chess I had no interest in chess I'm
like wow this is actually like really
interesting cuz the history and just the
entire premise of the chess is like
really really interesting the fact that
you'd like a lot of history yeah like
like off plate like it's basically like
this massive tournement hog you know
enemies times there's like reading about
some of like some like the most
historical chess games it was like it's
like I have no interest in chess but
this was [ __ ] hype and I was I
remember thinking man listen works so
well in an anime or manga setting so I
went out to try and find a single chess
anime or manga and there just wasn't one
and all right I was really really
disappointed it's it's surprising
honestly because like I think the whole
state
with chess in anime is like you know the
the [ __ ] like transfer student who
also happens to be like the daughter of
like the German company like the way
chess is used in anime is to make
someone look smart yeah like there's no
reason for a leash to play chess you
ever lead with the king corner for
example do it you wanna tell people
about your hidden like [ __ ] that
yellow chess champion sir why is 13 no
12 I just started high schools after I
left primary school I was playing
professional chess yeah and like parama
I like how I ended up in playing
professional chess is we had to begin
with because I never like played it much
I just liked video games along yeah so
video it was the only video game that my
dad would play with me yes yeah no
normal chess right but like I remember I
was playing it like year three how old
you in year three in the UK like eight
nine eight nine and the chess club is
only for the like the last year which
was like all the 12 year olds yeah and I
remember they wouldn't let me play with
them but one they let me play with them
and this is so anime right because yeah
because after outside of the Chess Club
I'd beat their best player in a game of
chess right and then they'd like no no
you gotta let this guy play with us yes
and so I beat them all and then I
nothing happened for like three years
until is my time to join the Chess Club
and I was allowed to join the tribe yeah
and then I was let I joined the Chess
Club and our school had lost like every
single chess tournament ever right
because yeah it was like a local I don't
even know we had this there's like a
local circuit right between all the
schools played each other like football
and yeah the other sport right yeah
there's one for chess and uh I remember
that we started playing in that and also
the guy who is number two in our
testings I have number one we were both
like equal yeah which is also very
animated everything on par with mine my
whole chess like experience its genuine
like an anime I'm gonna keep talking on
there's more stuff to it yeah and then
we just started like winning everything
like against every other school like it
wasn't even close I remember like these
kids were bad and I remember every time
they were like wait they would be like
shocked at how quickly we would beat
these kids yes yeah it's very different
a professional chance to playing it
somebody doesn't in professional chess
it's it's a long thing and I'll get more
into it later but and and these were
games I could win in 20 minutes all
right like I could see how they [ __ ]
up and I would take it and I to me it
just made sense right I didn't practice
I was just good at games and it made
sense and then one time there was a
school and these guys have been like
number one for like ten years in a row
or something because they had a guy who
was someone's parent and he's obsessed
with chess knows like he's very very
good chess and we beat his team and they
were like shocked they were like nany
you beat like the prodigy like this is
like a sports anime this is a [ __ ]
Sports anime good bass a chess Mong off
of your wife I remember thinking like it
was weird because this guy was making
like a whole come up bear mine I was
like 12 I don't know what the [ __ ] was
going on and this guy's making like a
whole commotion he was like shocked and
I was sitting then he was like walking
me through everything you did and I was
like I don't know I didn't write it down
cuz know she's gonna write it down
national chess and he was running it
down and I thought that was weird
and I said why would you write down your
moves you did you did them yeah you're
not gonna go back and he was like which
one which moved why did you move here
how did you know how to do that and
stuff and I was like I don't know I just
like did it yeah and then he spoke to my
mom and was like you should come to this
thing yeah it's like it's weird it's
like 200 kids come to a place yeah by
the way chess for like kids is a really
weird kind of thing that's it's really
it's just adults pushing a bunch of like
young bridge kids yeah so I went to a
location and there was like two three
hundred kids all just playing chess then
you would get like an opponent and if
you wanna lost you would then play
someone who is like one yeah and the
more you kept winning the more you would
go up and then eventually people who won
all their games go on to play for like
the area is the best horn Hawkeye was
killing all my games right and I had won
like four X you play 7-iron by won four
in a row they were really easy my friend
is well he'd lost like two and then he
was already out
[Applause]
see you in the finals like it's weird
because I never had any like a lot of
these kids as well they would be
studying it in between games but I would
just whip out like Pokemon and start
playing it yeah oh it's my time to go
and save play but I remember said like
my 5th game was against the guy I beat
in my school my prodigy team whatever
yeah and I took play him again and we
drew it was really like anticlimactic I
was like [ __ ] I beat him last time I
want to beat him again anyway I got on
the team and I was ok I was struggling
cuz this is where it was getting really
serious like I was decent enough where I
could win like 70% of my games but it
was still starting to get like really
long cuz chess games never went more
than an hour yeah and then they start
becoming like two hours yeah and I'm 13
I'm like this is Tana taken I just want
to play [ __ ] but I start winning and
then I got content they're like hey do
you want to play for your country and I
was like sure I guess I'll play for my
country why not yeah I'm doing good
enough so I turn up I go to the first
tournament you won't believe because I
was number 10 so there's 10 seats right
yeah one is the best 10th was so I was I
was the worst on their country what's
the country 13 yeah yeah guess who was
number one
I think I've told you guys this yeah
yeah it was like the main bully at my
school called make this [ __ ] or not it
was like the main bully at my school who
like no one knew he did this he pointed
[ __ ] we're like the flash back he was
the main rival
literally was the kid that everyone was
scared of and I remember thinking like
man he was really good at halo wars mm
that was weird right and then then
suddenly like he's really [ __ ] good
at chess he's amazing and he was winning
a law against like uh like really really
wicked good players bare mind when it
got to this point
it was pretty much me him and eight kids
who are gonna go to Cambridge know what
I mean the environment was really weird
as well and I remember just that was
when I really started to not enjoy chess
anymore is that when I remember woman
when I lost a game
I got [ __ ] bollocks by [ __ ]
the coaches they were furious at me
because they would take your sheep right
when you had to start riding at them
yeah they would take your sheet and they
would rinse you for your moves
they wouldn't they would watch you the
whole game so that's like always an area
of path where they can watch you yeah
like a god
and I remember if you made a move that
was under five minutes that was a
mistake
you got [ __ ] rinsed Frisch's they
were like you didn't you didn't think
long enough I've got to go through the
options cuz it gets to the point where
you're like you know that they're
thinking just as many moves ahead as you
are yes I just get really difficult
you're like [ __ ] like I haven't studied
enough at this point because I never
studied chess yeah but this is where I
was getting to the point where I was
against people who are naturally pretty
good but also was studying all the
[ __ ] time
yeah alright and it's just a really bad
environment I really didn't like it it
was just like like where I would finish
my games and I play pokemon they would
want to talk about so why did you move
rook to you know f2 you know why did you
do that did he was really impressive
when he moved his guys I was like my
turn
we are playing chess for eight hours
today I do not want to talk about Jesse
just yeah it was really weird
environment and I could I think if I
came into chess later in my life I would
have had a more healthy enjoyment of
chess yeah I still like to play it
occasionally but I think I'm just like
scarred from yeah the anime experience
that I had yes was like that's what I
found to find so fascinating about chess
is just like like here like talk talking
to you hear your chest doing like hear
it like reading up and watching like
Magnus Carlson's I think yeah his
stories and and how you were just like
you were just born and you just got the
game there like there are people who
just studied the game yeah and then
there are just people who just like a
genius is it and they don't know why
yeah it's it's like it's [ __ ] family
horn blows it's [ __ ] fascinating
it's it was weird because you kind of
like no matter how good you aren't
something and like how much raw talent
you have it's something when you start
competing at such a high level you start
to realize that like it doesn't matter
as much but also you meet people who
also like yeah you know there might be
like ten people in that country you also
have that same raw talent yeah right and
then it's like [ __ ] yeah cuz then it
starts to come it's like who can put
them cuz I didn't care about chess I
never cared about chess I was good at it
and I just played it because such a
thing that our protagonist
where where is the protagonist were to
go to my point lost and then been like
I'm gonna dedicate my life dude I was
like Pokemon Ranger just came spinning
it was just kind of like it gets to that
point when your life or you're like I
just I don't need this anymore and I and
I remember my parents are so sad because
I mean I don't know why my parents were
so invested and I think that it was a
mixture of proud and also they love
bragging about it of course your series
got canceled for failure at a spinoff
right so what happened is about when I
was like 15 16 or 17 I had like a
rejuvenation of my mind enjoyment
remember a website called MLG game
battles remember that I remember that
there's where you could like compete
against carpet jiya hooch s I remember I
would compete against like fully grown
men and beat them on Yahoo chastened
gets her pissed off and then I I joined
the local pub and that was a weird
experience so I joined the local pub
chess team and I remember Behrman they
were all like 80 to 40 year old men yeah
I never won one time I was playing
against a guy who looked like Ross Kemp
like the baby's like a skinhead
terrifying dude like he's like this over
the table like a brick [ __ ] every
every bouncer you see at a nightclub and
I'm like well I'm like like 15 16 like
this with my coke and he had like a pint
and like smoking like coke like Casey
checking my phone I don't know if that
that pissed him off but in between moves
I wouldn't look at what he was doing I
would just check my phone and I was like
because I'm normally thinking in my move
so I don't really pay much attention
yeah and I remember when I beat him and
he looked really [ __ ] angry I was so
scared
I was like believe you've done this
people people didn't like losing to a 15
year old battle for the law I mean yeah
I can understand I'm just really
committed to making this a manga Nelly
oh yeah please cuz like from a narrative
perspective there's so many interesting
ways you could tackle just
yes how come I want to take like that
concept of like you know your friend
being beaten in the preliminary just cut
to the scene where you're like in the
final and your friend is like that one
guy on Perseus just goes on with this is
gonna sad so nerdy that's one move and
chest that I always wanted to use I was
the icon I don't know the name of it but
it was the one where like if someone
moves they're like porn - and then like
in front of if you move your pawn - yeah
and they move it - as well that you can
then take it yeah dude
using a rook is a castling a zopi and
you always castle that's all I remember
like why do you console there's like
I'll tell you why I don't know because I
remember they try to teach us they're
like why don't he use the Indian prince
opening of 1970 I was like yes they
would they would when I would do an
opening move mmm I always did the same
opening moves I just liked it it was
like yeah nice and central reactant and
they would they would always say why did
you use that this person like yeah like
I said like the Indian prince move of
1764 yeah I was like I just like how the
bishop ghost just feels nice you know I
just feel it don't you explain it when
you're a kid cuz you're just like you're
just thinking four moves heading you're
like if this goes here and this goes
here and this goes here then you go that
you know I mean I just it's like any any
sport I imagine where kids are really
good at it
yeah adults are really pushy and kind of
like almost borderline some of the kids
I'd say they'd like a predatory
relationship with it yeah yeah because a
lot of them again like I said there they
were very rich parents whose kids went
to very good private schools and they
were destined to go to Cambridge or
Oxford no matter what and they would you
know exactly what I mean what kind of
kids I'm talking about yeah you spoke to
them you're like we're from a different
world
it's really awesome yes despite their
entire wall to them yeah it was like
something that was forced upon them
because it was you know it's something
that looks good on the resume when right
oh yeah yeah I'm very like yeah I mean
to be fair it got me a few good jobs or
helped a lot I remember some job
interviews where they
playing chess and they would bring it up
and it was like oh that's cute you're
good that's already you know I think
that's like a really interesting story
that you have yeah bottom line we need
to turn this into an anime yeah if
someone was like I want to like make a
chess anime I would absolutely find out
just like talk dr. Khanna has a very
interesting story
three stories race because like it's
just it's the perfect chance to like
teach people about how to play chess as
well I think it's a really good game and
it's one of my favorite things to like
sit down and talk to someone about just
talk and then VHS yeah it's a really
good way to and I just have exactly and
that's also fun beating people who think
that good a chance you'll meet people
who have just been like studying chess I
mean it's getting really big on twitch
right now yeah exactly white people who
are like you know they're like really
getting into it yeah and just like Tom
Thumb yeah it's like well you cuz okay
here's the thing right here's the worst
part about chess professionally is that
you normally know like five or six moves
in if you've lost or not but I have to
play it for another two and a half hours
and all it is the difference between
casual chat and professional chess is
the casually you always think you could
win if you outsmart them yeah personal
chess it's just like how do I drag this
out enough so that maybe they'll make a
mistake yeah yeah that's all God is
horrible it was awful I hated it cuz
they just got to the point right like
what's the [ __ ] point in this it's
like been control online it's just I'm
just I'm literally just being awkward
yeah you just go along in the inevitable
right yeah yeah and it's like I [ __ ]
up I [ __ ] up thirty minutes in I'm not
gonna put up with this but you know it's
like loading a game of League and then
five minutes in like your own sighting
is someone sensing the jungle is just
afk are you like can I just can I just
can I just F F now we just F F like is
this is like a diamond like a diamond
game right now I know no one's gonna
make a mistake you know I never got
praised for winning games they would
always be like good job
you know when they would praise me when
I made it [ __ ] hell for the other
person
when I this poor girl I I dragged it out
and she made a mistake to a stalemate
Barrett this game went on for like three
hours and 20 minutes or so it was
something [ __ ] long and I remember
I'd lost like an hour in a hundred
percent yeah and I just made it awkward
I wasn't playing to win anymore I was
playing to make it awkward for her yeah
and so I did things that you wouldn't
normally do to try and win would you do
it to cock-block everything still annoy
them but she was getting so stressed and
I remember being like this is kind of
fun but also like I hate this whole
jurors when I got back it was like
coming back into the football locker
room nice way to hell for that thirteen
year old girl like I was just like man I
didn't feel good okay I just like a
stalemate like yeah yeah I worked three
hours for a stale man like are you
kidding me absolute ease yeah there's
this other worse ones there where like
there was I remember there's people who
would constantly like cuz you can ask
for a draw yeah you want to draw [ __ ] me
I have my psychology off because I was
like does this mean I'm winning he's
losing at one time I remember I regret
it to this day I should have took the
drawing I lost [ __ ] gave me now that's
the lowness man that's the character
development we need yeah I know exactly
I got a little little trophy if you won
like three games professionally you got
a thing called a Wendy I don't know why
isn't called Wendy I don't know it just
says Wendy's Burger Wendy I'm sure
there's some chess people who know what
this is but I've no idea please please
leave I was so confused I was like why
does it not say my name I won these I'm
not Wendy I'm corner but I think I think
y'all sir if you google my name I think
my chess records come up in the really
oh wow if you dig deep enough we're
gonna find them yeah yeah you'll see
exactly which like County and country I
was playing for don't stalk in there
well is that in yeah I think is there
anything else you guys want I'm sorry
that was a huge deal I don't think we
can top that chest okay those thousand
intense that we just we just watched an
entire anime in my story I love telling
but it's one of those things where it's
like I can't bring it up if they're not
gonna be like invested in it cuz it's
such a long story but it's a very
interesting story I know the first time
you told me I was like this is we need
to talk about this publicly you've never
talked cuz like you know I bring it up
even imagine just being like yeah I was
a chess pro by accident I was like what
what you mean
all right yeah I probably underage dog
she's always really really good at video
games yeah I can always just click like
I'd always just caught them like to this
day I like i normally get video games
super quickly yeah yeah you just have
that tellement your Tensai funny it was
English spell you know if they gained
English I'd have been [ __ ] poor
I'd have been Pro it if they'd made it
like a spelling [ __ ] simulator I
think that's a good place in minutes
thank you guys for watching we love the
memes on the subreddit keep it up hey
shout out to the patreon as always if
you'd like your name on the screen right
now as you can see or you just like to
support the show then make sure to go
over to our patreon because it helps us
out a lot yes and we also have a
subreddit our / trash taste and also our
twitter twitter twitter twitter
titter our twitter i think i just
trashed a spot as well that's right so
sport a sport so make sure to follow us
on there give us keep giving us the
memes yeah Mimi's we love the me the
[ __ ] smash perceive you guys very
create with your memes and I if I don't
comment on all of them doesn't mean I
don't appreciate ya we go through the
sub resolve we see we see all of them
just for the record this was a diverse
episode of okay another thing so this
was this episode wasn't scripted at all
and none of our says our scripted but
sometimes we come in with a subject
matter in mind or theme but this one we
were just like what if we just sit down
just talk let's just let's just sit down
and start talking and we're not gonna
worry about yeah about what we're gonna
talk about we'll just talk about
whatever so if you enjoyed that give us
a comment because this is I think our
very first one that we just had nothing
we had nothing planned we we we could
have just sat here in silence I mean
like so what do you guys want to talk
about I guess what kind of like balance
do you guys want of like because I mean
we can do either we're comfortable doing
yeah I think I think we're really
interested which one strikes best with
you you guys like it when we just throw
it anime names talk about [ __ ] move on
or do you like the overall topic yeah
yeah make sure to smash that
[ __ ] like button as always and
subscribe I had a video and going
subscribe to our channel the [ __ ]
Bell
while this has been a trash taste and
I'm with the boys we'll see you next
time bye-bye
I gotta pee real bad
[Music]